[музика]
шановні пані та панове Вітаємо усіх вас
на всеукраїнському форумі Україна 30 сей
тиждень присвячений освіті освіті науці
ми поговоримо про те як зробити аби
освіта не була відірвано від науки а
наука від реального виробництва про все
це на форумі Україна 30 освіта
щотижня це місце ставатиме майданчиком
для головних тем України серія із 30-ти
масштабних щотижневих хворимів України
до річниці державної Незалежності
це великий діалог за участі влади
громадськості міжнародних партнерів
українських експертів децентралізація в
дії
її комп'ютер не бере хабаря форум - Це
пошук стратегій і такти величезний
поштовх економіки і будівництво в
Україні
інформаційної безпеки підвищення якості
ефективності чинного законодавства
Україна відкрито говорить і шукає
рішення збирає найкращі світовий досвід
економічні зв'язки між Україною та
Литвою всі мають визнавати
міжнародну визнані кордони європейські
Союз на боці України як і був завжди під
час форуму Влада спілкується з
журналістами
представники медіа беруть коментарі у
спікерів також відбувається спеціальні
сесії форуму
а буквально доторкнутися до теми можна в
експозоній формі
ці форми можуть дати вам розуміння
багатьох процес корисну інформацію та
відповіді на дуже важливі хвилюючі
запитання
форум Україна 30 це відкрита і пахова
розмова на найважливіші теми в житті
країни що є опорами нашої Незалежності
шановні пані та панове Вітаємо вас на
всеукраїнському форумі Україна 30 освіта
Вітайте на цій сцені президент України
Володимир Зеленський
[оплески]
[музика]
Доброго дня
Всім
доброго ранку
цього тижня в рамках форуму нашого
форуму Україна 30 ми говоримо про науку
ми говоримо про освіту ця тема на жаль
опиняється У фокусі уваги Україною
фокусі уваги суспільства та засобів
масової інформації не так часто як
наприклад політика
фінанси
судочинства або енергетика І
дійсно і ця тема викликає великі
суспільні дискусії не так часто і на мій
погляд абсолютно не заслужений
бо якщо ми з вами замислимось саме ця
тема є першочерговою і
і дуже важливою адже мова про навчання
виховання становлення наступних наших
українських поколінь людей які
творитимуть майбутню Україну і країна
яка дуже важливою
спроможною у сучасному світі має
визнавати освіту та науку своїми дійсно
стратегічними
пріоритетними сферами адже розвиток
демократичного успішного активного
суспільства розвиток будь-яких сфер будь
то безпека оборона будьте економіка
актуальна зараз завжди актуальна і
медицина промисловість і ті чи Агро все
це неможливо без добре освічених
ерудованих
креативних наших громадян
і їх підготовка має починатися не у 17
чи 18 років в університеті А майже
з народження саме тому Сьогодні наш
пріоритетом є розвиток кожної ланки
освіти
дошкільної початкової базової або
професійно-технічне вищої освіти та
подальшої освіти дорослої людини
протягом усього життя
їй і в кожній з них держава має
забезпечити кілька важливих я би навіть
сказав ключових умов необхідних для
цього успіху перший - це інфраструктура
починаючи від 19-го року в рамках
програми велике будівництво ми зробили
понад 150 шкіл та 100 садочків по всій
країні а до кінця року в планах
збільшити цю цифру до понад 200
важливими напрямками нашої роботи є
забезпечення швидкісного Інтернету та
комфортних шкільних автобусів для
сільської місцевості мова також і про
державні програми з Відродження
професійно-технічної освіти та
відновлення і розбудови
гуртожитків для наших студентів
якісна освітня інфраструктура - це
сучасні аудиторії спортивні майданчики
басейни їдальні лабораторії умови
проживання які об'єднані на основі
головного принципу доступних безпечних
комфортний і дуже важливо безбар'єрний
освітній простір
друга важлива умова - це
кадровий потенціал
кадровий потенціал працівники освіти і
науки не важлива це вихователь дитячого
садочку чи вчитель у школі чи викладач
університету або працівник наукової
установи всі вони мають мати високий
рівень кваліфікації
хорошу мотивацію гідні умови роботи та
гідні умови оплати
можливості для розвитку та особистісного
зростання
цього року ми
підвищили заробітні плати для нашого
освітян але
з зупинятись на цьому не можна ми
повинні знаходити нові механізми та
кошти для того щоб вони відчували
престижність своєї
професії а молоде покоління хотіли
працювати у закладах освіти
ми маємо
боротися за українських вчених
забезпечувати науково-технічну базу для
досліджень повинні активно
впроваджувати їх відкриття та інновації
в реальне життя сприяти їх участі у
міжнародних проектах і
зміцненню їх авторитету в світовому
середовищі науковців третя
Третя умова це щасливий та вмотивовані
здобувачі освіти цьогоріч були
запроваджені президентські стипендії для
кращих учнів з результатами ЗНО
переможців Всеукраїнських та міжнародних
олімпіад а також гранти президента на
навчання за кордоном нашої держави
держава має активне заохочувати успіхи
найкращих учнів та студентів забезпечити
Відкритий доступ і можливості
індивідуального навчання
протягом усього життя людини і четверта
умова - це зміст освіти
вона має давати не лише знання але й
розвивати важливі для сучасної людини
навички навички лідерства
саморозвитку креативного мислення
фінансової цифрової інформаційної
грамотності та багатьох інших багатьох
інших речей які дуже необхідні сьогодні
сучасні людині в XXI сторіччі Вона має
готуватися спеціалістів та Профі
відповідно запиту
завтрашнього дня
в цьому контексті Я хочу сьогодні
розповісти про одну нашу ініціативу в
Україні буде створено Президентський
університет - це заклад вищої освіти які
буде готувати людей майбутнього
який збере в одному місці кращих
викладачів і навчатиме спеціалістів що
зможуть вирішувати важливі державні
завдання для захисту нашої держави саме
держави
в дуже важливих пріоритетних
найактуальніших напрямках
напрямках сьогодення і завтрашніх
викликів для цього університет буде
годувати спеціалістів з інформаційною та
кібербезпеки
спеціалістів штучного інтелекту
нанотехнології
аерокосмічних енергетичних та
біотехнологій
наша мета - це найкращі умови найкращі
викладачі найкращі учні з усієї України
які будуть навчатися безкоштовно а потім
працювати в державі працювати тут
реалізуватись тут в Україні на благо
нашої держави на захист кожного українця
будь ласка увага на екран
освіта найпотужніший Інструмент що може
змінити світ людину історію Ми створюємо
університет президент це місце де знання
перетворюється на інновацію це простір
для професійного та особистісного росту
особистісний професійний та стратегічний
розвиток на цих трьох принципах
базується робота університету
більше практики та прикладних знань що
перетворюються на реальні дії продукти і
ногти вища освіта формує людину майбутнє
сміливу та розумну
Ми віримо в таких людей і створюємо
умови для їхнього розвитку університет
президент тут створюється майбутнє
це невеличкий ролик
[оплески]
Головне що буде давати цей університет
яких спеціалістів які дійсно будуть
працювати на державу
сьогодні та наступних наших всіх
спікерів Ви зможете дізнатись всі інші
важливі деталі а поки що із задоволенням
Я хочу підписати указ про створення
нашого університету президентського
університету має Будного Я вірю що в
цьому
[музика]
в цьому майбутньому ми зможемо втілити
головну форму для успішної українського
освіти та науки щасливі Наші вихователі
та вчителі щасливі викладачі науковці
щасливі діти щасливі батьки тож щасливо
Україна підписує Всім дякую за увагу
[оплески]
дождя
Дякуємо президентові України і вітаємо
із першим кроком для до створення нового
університету вітаємо
пані та панове Запрошуємо до слова
прем'єр-міністра України Дениса шмигаля
[музика]
Шановний пане президент України шановні
учасники сьогоднішнього форуму Доброго
дня всім треба сказати для початку що
Україна розуміє цінність людського
капіталу і характеристика того що ми є
третьою країною в Європі яка витрачає
6,5% свого ВВП на освіту це якраз
демонструє ось цю нашу відповідальність
і розуміння що ж таке людський капітал
його роль в економіці його роль для
розвитку і майбутнього країни звичайно
сьогодні завтра післязавтра під час
нашого форуму ми будемо багато говорити
про
стратегію системи освіти які можуть
прийти на заміну сучасним майбутнього
канадська можливо сингапурська
європейська різноманітні речі але
сьогодні ми маємо говорити також і про
прагматичні речі які вимагають від нас
реакції сьогодення це і зарплата
вчителів викладачів вихователів Як казав
президент України - це важливе завдання
цього року ми збільшимо заробітні плати
вчителів на 30%, Але звичайно наша мета
- це не менше ніж середня заробітна
плата по Україні має бути
скажем мінімальний базис для вчителів
для освітян звичайно ми маємо дати
достатню Кількість шкіл дитячих садочків
Тобто ми маємо створити сучасну
розвинуту інфраструктуру і президентська
ініціатива велике будівництво звичайно
забезпечує І сьогодні ми можемо говорити
Вже напевно враховуючи минулий рік цей
рік про сотні шкіл і садочків
новозбудованих в нашій державі Які
створюють якісну сучасну інфраструктуру
для освіти звичайно ми маємо говорити
про доступ до комп'ютера в сучасному
світі для кожної дитини і в цьому
контексті до кінця цього року більше 3
000 населених пунктів А це означає школи
в цих населених пунк і Діти зможуть
отримати доступ до високого швидкісного
інтернету і на цьому Ми зупинятися не
збираємося ми цю роботу Будемо
продовжувати і в контексті запровадження
5G вже з наступного року і в контексті
загалом доступу до Інтернету всім дітям
які цього потребують Звичайно що рівень
достатку сім'ї місця проживання не мають
грати вирішальну роль в тому щоби діти
які хочуть отримати освіту певної якості
і певного напрямку отримали її тому
звичайно розроблені на сьогоднішній день
системи і курси дистанційної освіти
також дають таку змогу і ми будемо
продовжувати працювати над підвищенням
якості і змоги і давати змогу дітям
вчитись більш якісно спільна програма зі
світовим банком на 200 мільйонів доларів
мотивація навчатись не лише для дітей
але і для вчителів тобто оце ті
прагматичні речі які Ми займаємося
сьогодні майже кожного дня на базі
Міністерства освіти Міністерства
цифрової трансформації ми будемо
вкладати більше одного мільярда гривень
в придбання техніки для шкіл і
навчальних закладів це власне от ті
прагматичні речі які ми уряд За
завданням президента в розвиток тої
ідеології яка в нас є освітньої
займається Практично кожен день дуже
важливо на чому хотілось би зосередити
увагу це дуальна освіта це такий елемент
державного приватного партнерства в
освітній галузі який надзвичайно добре
себе зарекомендував Ми розпочали з
експериментів на сьогоднішній день
очевидно що дуальна освіта - це майбутнє
тому що ми хочемо щоб наші діти як
сказав президент отримували не лише
теорію із якою потім не зрозуміло що
робити а виходили вже і практично
підготовленими і тому власне елементи
дуальної освіти особливо в
професійно-технічній сфері
критично важливі критично необхідні і
співпраця
освітян з бізнесом і з державою ось це
на сьогодні насправді формула успіху для
наших дітей для учнів для
професійно-технічного розвитку для
економіки в кінці кінців тому що маю
особистий досвід дуже такої ну
позитивної співпраці з навчальними
закладами і коли бізнес отримує
підготовлених спеціалістів які мають
хорошу теорію і хорошу практику і ось в
контексті цього
сьогоднішня ініціатива і підписаний
президентом указ про президентські
університет насправді підкреслює що не
лише професійно-технічній освіті але
вищій освіті ми також хочемо конкурувати
за надзвичайно високу якість освіти для
наших дітей коли декілька сотень дітей
на початку І декілька тисяч дітей в
подальшому зможуть отримувати якісну
базову освіту як в теорії так
збалансовано і в практиці друге Ці діти
не будуть
хвилюватись за своє майбутнє робоче
місце тому що вони в 90% випадках будуть
знати Куди вони підуть працювати або в
державну службу або на приватне приватну
компанію високотехнологічну або в
наукову установу де будуть продовжувати
реалізовувати свій науковий
дослідницький потенціал Звичайно це має
бути стійка взаємовигідна співпраця з
роботодавцями майбутніми і цей елемент
також про який я наголошував приватну
державного партнерства Я вважаю цю
ініціативу надважливою звичайно
впевнений що вже найближчий час ми
побачимо початок і реалізації і точно
найближчий час ми побачимо результати
реалізації цієї ініціативи президента
тому
якісній українській освіті бути точно
бути Слава Україні і успішної роботи
всім нам на цьому форумі дякую
[оплески]
дякую
Дякуємо за виступ
пані та панове всеукраїнський форум
Україна 30 - це унікальний майданчик до
30-річчя Незалежності України де
Протягом цього ювілейного року 30
форумів із різними темами де ми
порушуємо складні питання дискусійні
питання і найголовніше даємо на них
відповідь і відверто спілкуємося цей
тиждень присвячений дуже важливій темі
освіти і науки і також зазначу що не
тільки ви зможете завжди бачити виступи
наших спікерів різні обговорення але й
провідні представники українських
телеканалів радіо онлайн-видань завжди у
призалі спілкуються із нашими спікерами
і ставлять важливі питання Я певен що і
протягом цих трьох днів ви знайдете
відповіді на всі питання які стосуються
розвитку Української освіти і на Уки
пані та іванове Вітаю на цій сцені
міністра освіти і науки України Сергій
шкарлет
[музика]
Доброго дня шановний пане президенте
пане прем'єр-міністри Шановні колеги
освітяни науковці мені сьогодні випала
честь висока честь презентувати
внутрішню наповнюваність президентського
університету
але це не тільки внутрішня
наповнюваність всесвітній процес все
інше Це ще стратегічна візія того що ми
маємо закладати в сучасну освіту в
сучасну науку сучасні новації сучасний
розвиток суспільства
ви знаєте
перед нами перед країною вже майже 30
років постали питання суспільство
чітко усвідомлює що потрібні зміни і ми
обрали собі більше ніж два роки
президента який сказав Я за зміни Ідіть
за мною і ми пішли Ми пішли Але
президент в основу розвитку цього поклав
наймогутнішу зброю яка здатна змінити
світ це освіта і освіта теж потребує
певних змін потребує змін зсередини
потребує інституціональних змін фахових
змін кадрових змін і всього іншого тому
командою президента президентом особисто
було завдання створити новий майданчик
новий майданчик змін сфері вищої освіти
і це є Президентський університет де
випускники якого мають володіти якісними
знаннями лідерськими соціальними
навичками І що саме головне Вони мають
повертати набуті знання в суспільство і
творити нову хвилю інновацію стартапів
на чому ж можливість нашу освітній
простір по-перше це ми
формуємо саме ті напрями спеціальності
які є професіями майбутнього або
створюють шосту хвилю технологічного
нового технологічного вкладу шостого
хвилю інновації і процес формується
виключно на засадах сучасного
науково-простіру і знання повертаються з
теорії одразу в практику
в основі президентського університету
закладено трип
персоналіті Profession Progress
індивідуальність Професіонал і здатність
до стратегічного розвитку в цій
концепції в розвиток кожного з елементів
особистості ми вкладаємо мотиваційне
лідерство психологічний розвиток
комунікації баланс між теорією практикою
Тім лідерством знання виробничих та
бізнес-процесів а також здатність
кожного випускника і кожного викладача в
освітньому процесі до проведення
досліджень розробки інновацій розробки
стратегії та управління всіма ризиками
пов'язаними з освітою
освітні напрями які вкладені в
президентській освітній процес
президентського університету це перш за
все ті 6 стратегічних постаті які ми
маємо наповнити реальним знанням
інформаційна технологія кібербезпека
нанотехнології аерокосмічні технології
біотехнології та науки про здоров'я
енергетика і глобалізація та міжнародні
комунікації по кожній з них кожен з моїх
колег дасть Більш детальну наповненість
що саме головне Ми представляємо Я дуже
коротко представлю основні елементи
наповненості кожних з цих стратегічних
освітніх напрямів в рамках з
спеціальності які можуть бути
запропоновані до навчання в
президентському університеті
це і нанотих космічні енергетичні
біотехнології глобалізація та міжнародні
комунікації що є здавалось би не
інформаційним суспільством але це є саме
напрямок нашої комунікації і утвердження
держави як професійної проривної держави
в світі
знову ж таки навколо концепції
президентського університету все
базується на цих трьох п відступного
тестування і формування знань щодо
розробки проекту кожної особистості
формування професійних навичок і вступні
внутрішні міжнародній стажування а також
формування фінального тестування і
завдань на проектне дослідження
Ми формуємо навички майбутнього і з ті
хто б дев'яти навички ми виділили по
кожному з напрямів
персональних прогрес ті стратегічні
мислення ті критичні мислення і ті
управлінські навички які формують топ
навичок майбутнього і саме їм буде
навчати саме їм буде саме їх буде
Формувати в президентському університеті
розвитку особистості базується на
ключових темах таких як компетентність
але не тільки технічна ще й поведінкова
комунікативні навички мотивація до
розвитку та наставництва як менторство
як Повернення знань в життя і це життя
формує нову хвилю інновації нову хвилю
життя нові старти
реалізація освітнього процесу
передбачається за всіма напрямами Які
можливі бакалавр магістр мба MBA і
доктор філософії Але стартуватиме маємо
звичайно ж з бакалаврату
при цьому що характеризує особливості
освітнього процесу президентського
університету найкраще викладачі та
методики перш за все вітчизняні
українські кастинг як студентів так і
викладачів великі кастинг методик
великий кастинг всіх тих комунікативних
навичок викладача які здатні породжувати
нових менторів нових суспільних діячів
нових інноваторів нових науковців
запрошені також іноземні експерти але не
тільки на коротку програму А на повний
курс який здатний буде формувати навички
з практичним кейсом в житті
президент в своїй промові сказав що 30%
лише теорії все інше занурення в кейси
реальних підприємств з можливістю
відпрацювання наслідків тих чи інших
управлінських рішень і перевірки їх на
практиці при цьому головною головним
елементом практики буде стажування як в
Україні так і за кордоном
а також реалізація власних наукових
проектів в частині роялті Якщо так як це
робиться в провідних університетах світу
Оксфорд кембріджіль масачусенський
технологічний та інші вони на цьому
стоять і ми маємо для того щоб створити
Президентський університет ми маємо
крокувати в ногу з тими світовими
стандартами які сьогодні є
умовою перебування в президентському
університеті як здобувачів так і
науково-педичних працівників є певні
гарантії які закладаються в основу
життєдіяльності цього університету перш
за все цей соціальний пакет Це
безкоштовне навчання це грант та
навчання велика стипендія це є умови
соцстрахування які закладені перш за все
в саме в основу
в основу перебування студента і
викладача в цьому університеті це умови
працевлаштування в перш за все в
державному секторі і перш за все
можливості цих студентів принести
користь держави і генерувати новий нову
хвилю державного поступового розвитку
Але при цьому Ми закладаємо також
елемент трансферу цих розумних молодих
людей якщо бізнес захотів придбати собі
такого реально придбати собі такого
розумного молодого інноватора Він може
на умовах трансферу запровадити всю цю
ініціативу але
принаймні в трикратному розмірі
компенсувати державі принаймні в
трикратному компенсувати державі все те
що держава за- витратила на підготовку
цього інноватора
старт навчального процесу старт
освітнього процесу 1 жовтня 23 року якщо
ми хочемо щоб ми занурились світовий
освітній простір або третій тиждень
вересня або 1 жовтня так як в цьому
світі і якщо ми будуємо світовий
визнаний Президентський університет Він
має відповідати всім трендам на навчання
які сьогодні є в світі
основою університету є новий порядок
нормативної і нормотворчої діяльності
новий закон на нових підставах коли ми
стартували Я дуже дякую Володимиру
Олександровичу за те що він занурений в
освіту і багато інновації йде в освіті
але освіта дуже
консервативна галузь скільки ми не
вносили змін законодавство скільки ми
наробили спроб але при цьому стара
історія злітає дуже довго
законсервативності освіти тому прийнято
рішення абсолютно на нових підставах
абсолютно з нової історії абсолютно з
нуля стартувати з цим університетом перш
за все це вільна економічна зона для
всіх бізнес-партнерів які долучені до
формування цього університету це
формування кошторису на утримання
університету і за державний бюджет і за
партнери бізнес компанії і за
міжнародний донорські фонди
з задоволенням хочу ще раз подякувати
президенту України за ту велику
підтримку в галузі освіти яка сьогодні
відбувається в державі дякую вам
[оплески]
охорони здоров'я України Віктор Ляшко
[музика]
Вітаю Бажаю всім міцного здоров'я пане
президент пане прем'єр-міністр
сьогоднішні виклики для сфери охорони
здоров'я показують що медицина не може
бути самостійною вона іде нога в ногу з
інженерією
сьогоднішнє наші студенти не можуть бути
просто студентами медиками сьогодні
студенти повинні встановитись
конструкторами
дослідниками
винахідниками і щоб все це зробити в
одному ключі Ми довго думали і вирішили
запустити новий етап підготовки наших
студентів в рамках реагування до нових
загроз і окремий кластер в університеті
президента буде присвячений
біотехнологія
біологічні загрози
хронічні на інфекційні захворювання
старіння населення
величезна кількість збудників які
викликають захворювання як в людини так
і в тварини це все ті загрози До яких ми
повинні готовитись до них ми можемо
готовитись коли ми поєднаємо
біотехнології і поєднаємо
предмети нашої науки про здоров'я і саме
в університеті президента Ми хочемо
створити єдиний простір інноваційний
простір який буде говорити про центр
біотехнологій аудиторії Де студенти
здобувають знання який створить потужну
надсучасну лабораторію з рівнем захисту
басейн-3 а також університетську клініку
саме в цих умовах в цьому інноваційному
єдиному просторі студенти здобудуть
знання і будуть розпочинати
попереджувати свої ідеї в практику без
цього неможливо розвитку без цього
країна буде беззахисна І саме
університет президента дає нам надію що
ми запустимо взагалі новий початок
історії і новий початок національної
безпеки України так наші плани амбітні
але ми в нашому університеті президента
беремо найкраще що є в світі але Зробимо
ще краще ніж є в світі і для цього в нас
є потенціал У нас є ресурс і в нас є
можливості медицина майбутнього буде
реалізована тут Україна буде готова до
всіх викликів розпочнемо 1 жовтня
2023 року але не зупинимось ніколи
Україна буде новим лідером біотехнологій
Дякую за увагу
[оплески]
запрошуємо на сцену
віце-прем'єр-міністра міністра цифрової
трансформації України Михайло Федорова
[музика]
да Всім доброго дня Дякую за можливість
сьогодні бути на даній події Я хотів
сказати що сьогодні і ви все це ви все
ви всі знаєте про це ми активно
трансформуємо нашу державу будуємо
цифрову державу на сьогодні Нам вдалося
побудувати унікальну організаційну
структуру і дуже багато молодих людей
вже працюють в напрямку цифрової
трансформації нашої держави в нас є
заступники цифрової трансформації в
кожному міністерстві в нас є цифрові
депутати і в нас взагалі відбувається
цифрова трансформація кожного напрямку в
нашій державі в нас є така амбітна ціля
амбітна мета за три роки зробити дуже
зручну державу але розвиток буде
продовжуватися і Нам буде потрібно
постійно бути першими у світі для того
щоб бути інноваційною країною для того
щоб
багато неефективних процесів замінити
технологіями і нам потрібні менеджери
які будуть керувати всіма процесами і ми
вважаємо що Президентський Університет
може стати фундаментом і базою взагалі
для того щоб
заповнювати державу топ-менеджерами які
будуть і в подальшому займатися цифровою
трансформацією нашої країни тому що це
процес який буде відбуватися постійно Ми
сьогодні бачимо Що
найшвидше зростає ті країни які
переходять вже на формат і на розвиток
цифрової економіки а це цифрова
трансформація кожної галузі тільки на
сьогодні команда уряду трансформує і
реалізовує 92 проекти це 380 під
проектів це велика кількість різних
рішень це велика кількість
відповідальних велике об'єм
відповідальності і нам потрібно
будувати державу на фундаменті таких
людей які розуміють як стати першою
країною в світі і тому я вважаю що
Президентський університет буде таким
певним фундаментом наступне нам здається
що та модель яка сьогодні вже
сьогодні і презентував Міністр освіти
яка є фундаментом університету вона
інноваційна вона нестандартна І це
взагалі модель майбутнього управління
вищий навчальним закладом і
Президентський університет університет -
це такий
виклик це такий
пуш для того щоб взагалі відбулася
цифрова трансформація
it галузі it освіти Ми хочемо і в цьому
році буде прийнятий законопроект Про
дієсity як ціль якого в три рази
збільшити надходження
it-галузі об'єм надходжень і в два рази
збільшити кількість людей які працюють в
галузі ми так на сьогодні третя країна в
світі з точки зору аутсорсингу але ми
бачимо який дефіцит кадрів і там модель
управління яка закладена В
президентському університеті вона
стимулює взагалі
it освіту в інших навчальних закладах
для того щоб вона пришвидшувалася в
реалізації і тому на цьому тижні вже
буде офіційно створена група і з
працівників університетів і з
представників
міністерств і галузі яка
буде займатися трансформацією
it освіти і в інших закладах навчальних
закладах тому що нам наступні кілька
років потрібно зробити стрибок для того
щоб наповнити ринок молодими
професіоналами які будуть працювати
вийти галузі тому
наша команда підтримує
Президентський університет ми вважаємо
що даний проект Це ще один важливий крок
для того щоб про нашу країну в світі
говорили як про інноваційну країну як
про країну яка розвивається дуже швидко
і Я впевнений що вже через кілька років
коли там перші студенти стануть
студентами даного вищого навчального
закладу нам вдасться зробити всі нашій
команді дуже багато для того щоб вони
гідно після цього працювали в нашій
державі Дякую передаю слово Юрій щигелю
[оплески]
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні пане президенте
шановні друзі всі ми знаємо і розуміємо
що виховання інтелектуального покоління
я запорукою безпеки нашого майбутнього і
оскільки кібербезпека - це галузь
складна та технологічна в першу чергу
вона потребує якісної освіти
безпека інформації це в першу чергу
якісна освіта та наука і вже потім
вміння та навички застосовувати це все в
віртуальному просторі для захисту нашої
держави кожен українець який
користується цифровими послугами
сучасної
сучасними сучасними інтернетом а це
майже все населення нашої країни повинен
знати що у випадку якщо він не виконує
заходи безпеки він несе загрозу в першу
чергу як для себе так і для всіх
оточуючих ми вже маємо фахівців
світового класу які готові працювати в
нашій державі ми виконуємо виховуємо
спеціалістів які готові працювати для
держави але цього замало цілі галузі
державні підприємства та І взагалі всі в
нашій країні розуміють що у нас велика
нестача фахівців кібербезпеки всі ми
пам'ятаємо приклад 2017 року коли
вірусна Петя на ніч збитки понад 10
мільярдів доларів Всього за кілька днів
і це надзвичайно багато крім того світ
це є цифровим про це діджуціалізація
незворотній держава насправді стає
зручною для громадян і державна служба
спеціального зв'язку та захисту
інформації сам відповідає саме за
кібербезпеку і ми станемо однією з тих
платформ які будуть практично
реалізовувати в університеті технології
кіберзахисту галузь безпеки інформації
охоплює різні напрямки це є високі
технології виявлення та реагування на
кіберзагрози складні сфери криптографії
та крипто-аналізу виробництво апаратних
та програмних комплексів захисту
інформації проектування систем
кіберзахисту а також високий рівень
менеджменту та політику правління за
останні роки роки відверто які агресії
ми відчуваємо брак потужного
професійного та вмотивованого кадрового
кіберрезерву сьогодні в Україні вже
існують навчальні заклади які готують
фахівців із
кібербезпеки але цього також недостатньо
ми постійно працюємо над покращенням
методичного та наукового потенціалу
нашої освіти цього року спільно з
міністерством освіти та науки було
затверджено стандарт вищої освіти
кібербезпеки для спеціалізації Магістр
але і цього замало Нам необхідно
будувати потужну систему підготовки
кадрів в галузі безпеки інформації ми
щиро вдячні президенту за глибоке
розуміння питання та ініціативу створити
заклад вищої освіти і кому будуть
реалізовані міжнародні передові практики
та Сучасні підходи у сфері кібербезпеки
це рішення демонструє всім що в державі
є розуміння безпека інформації - це
насамперед здатність держави захистити
себе та здатність захистити кожного
громадянина і підготовка майбутніх
фахівців в рамках окремої галузі знань
дозволить нам систем но реформувати та
створити матеріально-технічну базу для
підготовки кадрів таке рішення
відповідає сучасним потребам
національної безпеки воно відповідає
також сучасним потребам захисту
суспільства та дозволить нам збудувати
потужну систему підготовки кадрів задля
майбутнього нашої держави і маючи такі
підтримку результат буде стовідсотково
Дякую за увагу
[оплески]
дякуємо дякуємо
запрошую до слова першого заступника
голови Верховної Ради України Руслана
стефанчука
[музика]
Ви знаєте я в попередньому своєму житті
до політики все своє життя про провів в
освіті науці і тому для мене
сьогоднішній форум я от просто така
професійна віддушина тому що я
усвідомлюю що нашій державі важливе є
майбутнє тому що пройшов той період коли
сила і міць держави визначалася
кількістю металобрухту яку ти можеш
вивести на кордон своєї країни вона
визначається кількість інтелекту яку ти
вкладаєш в систему управління цим
металобрухтом і тому надзвичайно важливо
що ми сьогодні стоїмо на стадії
абсолютно іншого усвідомлення що таке є
філософська усвідомлення що таке освіта
і наука вона багато більш ширше ніж
просто підручник я навчання передачі
інформації для нас українців це взагалі
є надзвичайно така особлива тема тому що
освіта в нас починається з першого слова
яке мати говорить от свої де- дитині і
завершується останніми словами які старе
по покоління яке вже відчуваю що аби
відходить як мудрість передає а
наступним поколінням і то мені здається
що от цієї системи спадковості цієї
системи
Дякую з цієї системи спадковості ми
павловині зрозуміти що ми стоїмо на
якісно іншому підході А який в нас
формується на якісна іншому рівні освіти
і науки тому дуже важливо що лідерство
зберігається в першу чергу за
президентом здавалось би з одного боку
ну
президенту освіта президента інші
напрямки по Конституції так от ні Якраз
коли ви подивитесь ці напрямки які
закладені в основу президентського
університету то всі вони спрямовані
якраз на забезпечення національної
безпеки тому що як я вже говорив
Національна безпека це не кількість
металобрухту це вміння управляти чи
через технології це вміння протидіяти
атакам хакерським це вміння захистити
населення своєї країни від мікро зброї
яка вкидується на світовий рівень і це
вміння це все проговорити на рівні
держав-партнерів тому тут включені і
питання е-е глобального між народного
спілкування і тому мені видається що ця
ідея є надзвичайно важливою надзвичайно
актуальною і це перший але мега важливий
крок для зміни і підходу до нового рівня
освіти і науки Але зрозуміло що ну в
нашій державі Нічого не робиться без
того щоб воно було завернуто в обгортку
законопроекту і ми починаємо розробку
законопроекту я думаю що А ближчим часом
тому що всі загальні питання вже
пропрацьовані ви по- побачите цей
законопроект він буде стосуватися
окремий окрема така одиниця як при
прецедентського університету що важливо
там буде закладно крім того що ми от
будемо прописувати структуру оці всі
речі про які говорили колеги Мені
здається що дуже важливо в ньому
віднайти ще і роль інтелектуальної
власності як незаконно такої забутої за
вже весь період а незалежності України і
її місця і ролі в розвитку університетів
і науки в цих в цілому і тому мені
здається що дуже важливо треба говорити
про
врешті-решт запровадження в Україні
інтелектуальних трансферів тому що для
мене завжди було дивно чому коли
наприклад прекрасні футболіст Андрій
Шевченко з Київського Динамо переходить
в Мілан Мілан отримує от кошти
трансферні А коли з України виїжджає
дуже багато науковців Україна як держава
не захищає свій інтерес тому мені
здається тут теж ми а ми повинні дещо
почати дискусію щодо того що формуючи
націю інтелектуалів Ми повинні отримати
відповідний державний от захист що що ще
До цього і друге важливе питання це
питання того питання долученості тому що
студенти які і викладачі які будуть
працювати Вони повинні отримувати рівні
права інтелектуальній власності на
створений ними продукт так працює весь
світ тому ще раз я вітаю з цією
прекрасною подією Я глибоко переконаний
що все в нас вдасться тому що українці
мегаінте лектуальна нація ви подивіться
Пантеон інтелектуалів світу великий
відсоток за українцями тепер наша за
задача зберегти і примножити і створити
всі умови щоб українці могли
реалізуватися в нашій прекрасній державі
Дякую Слава Україні
і від теми законодавчої бази освіти для
освіти і науки переходимо до
Міжнародного досвіду і Я запрошую до
слова президента Київської школи
економіки радника керівника офісу
президента України Тимофія мелованова
[музика]
Добрий день для мене це честі привілегія
бо освіта і наука є справою мого життя
я хвилююся я хочу
я хочу щоб Україна була щаслива Я хочу
щоб майбутні покоління наших дітей були
щасливі Я вчора був в Умані в школі де
діти працюють на комп'юторах 2006 року у
них намагаються відтиснути це приміщення
бо Земля є дорога а парти - це ще ті
парти на яких я вчився в Радянському
Союзі знаєте Такі от ну дерев'яні в них
там металеві Ну ви дізнаєтеся Я фотки
повішу це не має так бути немає так бути
Я працював 15 років в університетах
Сполучених Штатів Америки в різних
втопових пенсільватському Державному
Університеті мене тренували і вчили Що
якщо ти бачиш
якусь якесь порушення закону на
території університету ти маєш
повідомити або в поліцію або керівнику і
якщо ти це не робиш тебе можуть посадити
в тюрму я бувшакований Я запитав а чому
так чому якщо я перейду на 2 м через
дорогу і побачив що людину гвалтують я
можу бігти і ховатися і не маю
підставлятися фоткати і стучати Вибачте
за таке слово а коли я на території
університету я маю Мені відповіли тому
що на в університетах в школах дитячих
садках ми будуємо майбутнє і там
ситуація має бути краще за те
суспільство яке є сьогодні І тому ми
порушуємо трохи незалежність людини яка
там працює і вимагаємо щоб вона захищала
майбутнє і тому на тобі відповідальність
якщо ти бачиш зраду Перепрошую в
університеті де є діти ти маєш цю зраду
повідомити або сядеш в тюрму так жорстко
ставиться в Сполучені Штати Америки до
своїх майбутніх дітей в мене таких
прикладів багато як працює поліція якщо
ви підійшли продали наркотики зовсім
інший строк тощо тощо
і ми маємо стати такими але давайте
повернемося до реалії сьогодні Сполучені
Штати Америки витрачають 10 тисяч
доларів на одного учня в рік 12-14 на
студентах на
студента в університету вони витрачають
в середньому 34 тисячі доларів в рік на
людину
ми маємо бути умними розумними для того
щоб виграти в цій гонці щоб нас здогнати
у кожній країні своя стратегія у Китая
своя у нас має бути своя і навіть наша
має бути
А я презентація
це новина
але хай буде
нема а Окей добре дякую Хай буде так
дивіться ми маємо бути Так порозумному
хитрими у нас є сила сила полягає в
певних галузях де є бізнес ми маємо
використати те що робили американці
створити державні приватні партнерство
навіть в Гарварді сьогодні тільки 20%
приватних найкращий 20% і де від
студентів 30 від донорів але 50 Це
контракти від бізнесу дуальна освіта
спільне навчання якісь дослідження
практики і так далі ця можливість У нас
сьогодні є Нам потрібно будувати
Президентський університет Я дуже
пишаюся що є Президентський університет
це увага політична увага до важливого
питання але вся країна весь бізнес Я
дуже прошу бізнес Почніть думати хтось з
вас це робить а хтось ні Почніть думати
яким чином ви можете в своєму
профільному вишу свої профільній школі
профтех училище ви можете допомогти щось
разом створити Не бійтеся освіта і наука
має стати модними в цій країні і Бізнес
має так само працювати прийдіть в школу
Подивіться на їх бюджет помножте на два
і скажіть це наша відповідальність дати
50%. так працює світ так працює Приват
капіталізм Сполучені Штати Америки
50%. це бізнес дає університетом школа
так має стати у нас тому я всіх дуже
прошу якщо ми хочемо вижити і бути
успішною державою давайте вкладати в
освіту та науки Я дуже вдячний
президенту України Володимиру
Олександровичу зеленському за те щоб він
піднімає це питання на національний
рівень - це справжнє лідерство Дякую
всім дякую
[оплески]
дякуємо дякуємо
Дякуємо усім нашим доповідачам зовсім
скоро ми розпочнемо
вузько-тематичні сесії із фахівцями на
цій сцені А я дякую президентові України
і прем'єр-міністру України за участь у
форумі Україна 30
[оплески]
вже за кілька хвилин на цій сцені ми
розпочнемо першу дискусію українська
освіта і наука у світовому вимірі про
все це на формі України 30 за кілька
хвилин
знання - це скарб а вміння вчитись ключ
до нього українська освіта змінюється
[музика]
вона стає гнучкішою і сучаснішою
цифровою і безбар'єрними наука все
більше цікавить молодь розробки і
винаходи перетворюються на стартапи а
держава підтримує і мотивує
всеукраїнський форум Україна 30 освіта і
наука
Уряд не відмовлятиметься від безоплатної
вищої освіти і держзамовлення на певні
спеціальності в міносвіти і науки
вважають що це стимулюватиме ті галузі
які відчувають кадровий голод водночас
за даними міносвіти науки зменшується
державне замовлення на юристів
економістів і фахівців у публічному
управлінні і збільшується в інших
галузях наприклад сфери it Нано та
біотехнології потребують втричі більше
фахівців
[музика]
Ми зараз прибуваємо в експозонії поруч
із основною залою де відбуваються наші
дискусії і виступи спікерів протягом цих
днів трьох ми ознайомимо вас із цікавими
експозиціями наприклад зараз я на
території такої виїзної експозиції музею
освіти і науки малої академії науки це
надзвичайно цікаво протягом цих трьох
днів форумом будемо обговорювати питання
і української вищої освіти і шкільництва
тобто середня освіта зачепили у своїх
виступах і президенти Прем'єр
залікомплексні підходи які стосуються
навіть концепції неперервної освіти і це
абсолютно цікава практика і Західна і у
нас уже певні проекти реалізовувалися
коли наприклад або спортивний напрямок
або творчий дитячий садок спеціалізована
школа наприклад музична потім далі
бакалаврат це може бути училища коледж і
уже здобуття магістратури і далі наукова
робота яка може бути неперервна так само
це практикується і в інших
спеціальностях крім цих двох популярних
мистецтво і напрямках і е-е спорт
поговоримо про розвиток української
науки про
точковий фінансування
в рамках конкурсів окремо взятих
наукових проектів про можливість
реального державного приватного
партнерства чому воно важливе для науки
тому що партнером і у фінансуванні того
чи іншого наукового науковий розробки
наукового відкриття досліджень
виступають не просто приватні особи а як
найчастіше потенційні замовники і
виробники того аби у нас не нарощувалися
величезна кількість винаходів які не
застосовуються а справді те що могло би
сприяти
підвищенню ВВП і запуску нових
виробництв і
розвитку цієї сфери і зауважте хто
слухав надзвичайно хороший коментар
слушний якраз був від першого місця
спікера Верховної Ради Руслана Стефаника
щодо інтелектуальної власності адже в
сучасному світі винахід - це не
обов'язково якийсь тумблер якого можна
взяти в руки і побачити це може бути
ідея Наукова це може бути концепція це
може бути бачення розвитку стратегія
чогось і ось це якраз і є чого не
вистачає зараз відповідно до
законодавства щодо того як варто оцінити
цей науковий твір це відкриття і потім
його використовувати ми обов'язково
зачепимо питання появи
неочікуваного і не прогнозованого попиту
Ще два роки тому до коронавірусу
ситуації із попитом на такі рідкісні
здавалося раніше професії пов'язані із
біотехнологіями і з
вірусологією те що зараз постає і
надзвичайно стає актуальним в усьому
світі в тому числі і в Україні і про
можливості майбутні виклики загалом для
людства про що уже не раз попереджають
на виступах всесвітньої організації
охорони здоров'я до цього варто бути
готовим і чи буде готова українська
наука освіта Теж про це ми поговоримо
щотижня це місце ставатиме майданчиком
для головних тем України серія із 30
масштабних щотижневих хворимів України
до річниці державної Незалежності
це великий діалог за участі влади
громадськості міжнародних партнерів
українських експертів децентралізація в
дії комп'ютер не бере хабаря форум - Це
пошук стратегій і тактий величезний
поштовх економіки і будівництво в
Україні
інформаційної безпеки підвищення якості
ефективності чинного законодавства
Україна відкрито говорить і шукає
рішення збирає найкращі світовий досвід
економічні зв'язки між Україною та
Литвою всі мають визнавати
міжнародну визнані кордони європейські
Союз на боці України як і був завжди під
час форуму Влада спілкується з
журналістами
представники медіа беруть коментарі у
спікерів також відбуваються спеціальні
сесії форуму
а буквально доторкнутися до теми можна в
експозоні форуму
ці форми можуть дати вам розуміння
багатьом процесів корисної інформації та
відповіді на дуже важливі хвилюючі
запитання
форум Україна 30 це відкрита і факова
розмова на найважливіші теми в житті
країни що є опорами нашої Незалежності
це всеукраїнський форум Україна 30 і ми
знову на основній сцені і готові
розпочати першу дискусію першу сесію яка
присвячена українській освіті і науці у
світовому вимірі із поважними експертами
спілкуватиметься десь присутніми у залі
модераторка цієї дискусії телеведуча
Оксана гутсайд бажаю плідної дискусії
Всім доброго ранку дякую
це заздалегідь нашим спікерам Так
Сьогодні ми з вами говоритимемо
говоритимемо зі спікерами але ви можете
задавати свої питання приєднуватися до
нашої розмови і говоритимемо про те
Якими мають бути освіта та наука
майбутнього Як на них впливають нові
технології і взагалі яке місце
української освіти і науки у світовому
вимірі і я хочу одразу представити своїх
спікерів так ваші Оплески Тимофій
малованов президент Київської школи
економіки радник керівника офісу
Президента України
Сергій шкарлет Міністр освіти і науки
України
Анатолій Загородній президент
Національної академії наук України
лорабіл заступниця голови представництва
дитячого фонду ООН в Україні
Аліса ляліна керівниця напрямку освіти і
науки офісу президента України
Руслан Гурак голова державної служби
якості освіти України
онлайн з нами Соломія Шпак головна
експертка Департаменту фінансової
стабільності НБУ професорка Київської
школи економіки ваша оплески
і трохи згодом до нас приєднається
Сергій Бабак це голова комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновації Шановні спікери я
пропоную зробити так в нас невеличкий
час 60 хвилин тому давайте Спочатку ми
кожному дамо слово а вже потім будемо
слухати запитання або від аудиторії або
від мене або може ви захочете задати
один
у мене вчора у нас навчили так в Штатах
з особисті приклади завжди давати інакше
воно не щиро Да От в мене вчора прийняли
наукову статтю в одному стопових
журналів економічних
Скажу чесно я не дуже над нею працював
останній рік то мої співавтори Але
раніше я працював на дні і в мене два
співавтора один росіянин один українець
росіянин в Австралії давно поїхав з
Росії там не знаю 10-15 років вчився
виметі а
українець - це він працює здається в
сент-ендрюс це Великобританії в
університеті і де тільки він не працював
і в Німеччині працював і до речі в
Україні теж працював повертався на певні
періоди це приклади це ще такі люди які
якось пов'язані з нами а ще в мене є
багато співавторів Які є повністю
міжнародні да хтось з Індії хтось штатів
і так далі І сьогодні так Ну як як
мінімум в нашій галузі так працює
для цього нам потрібно бути частиною
цієї світової галузі у нас мають бути
міжнародні конференції частина є але ми
можемо робити більше нам потрібно щоб
співавторство були Нам потрібно щоб ми
відправляли своїх людей вчитися або на
обмін і повертали їх я наведу приклад як
Китай для мене Китай їх стратегія - це
щось таке неперевершено в 2000-х роках
на мільйон людей Вони відправляли 3-4
людини в штати вчитись
Україна так само це означає для нас там
до 2000 людей і оці всі 20-30 років воно
так і гуляло дві-три ну 2-3 тисячі людей
від нас вчаться в Сполучених Штатах
Америки так було і в Китаї там 30 60 000
на сьогоднішній день вони довели це до
200 тисяч тобто вони збільшили це в 6
разів кількість людей які вони
відправляють тепер постає питання це
витягують мізки з Китаю чи вони вчать їх
і повертають у Китаю була та сама
проблема як і у нас в них з тих хто
їхали вчитися за кордон і ставали
науковцями більшість залишалися там і
тільки поверталося 17% нас до 2000 рік
17%.»
і в 5-6 разів збільшили кількість людей
які повертаються відсоток
тобто Якщо раніше в 2000-х виглядало що
Америка витягує мізки з Китаю наукові то
сьогодні виглядає що це насправді Китай
вирішив не будувати дуже дорогу систему
науки і освіти і просто аутсорсить і
витягує знання звідти і привозить назад
І от ми таким шляхом теж можемо йти
створювати умови коли люди повертаються
до нас
відправляти туди більше робити спільні
програми обмін подвійні дипломи і так
далі тощо да І от це для мене була б
стратегія така одна з елементів да
стратегій як боротися з відтіком мізки
розвернути повністю систему на
180°, як зробив Китай замість того щоб
відтягувати людей навпаки
використовувати те що я в світі
найкращий і повертати до нас от В мене
така є такий є коментар Ну поки ми в
основному мабуть стоїмо на першій стадії
Китаю коли да наші люди діти їдуть туди
вчитися але основна маса вона там
залишається за кордоном в Америці в
Канаді Ну де б не вчилися Ну так і ні
тобто На Це теж треба дивитися ну з
більш такої дистанції Я наприклад
повернувся Соломія теж повернулася це
тільки по економіці я можу сказати 15-20
У нас є
HD ну докторів які повернулися в Україну
Це тільки у нас це тільки у нас А
скільки по всій Україні друге що багато
є залученими залученими в сенсі так вони
працюють там але значну частину часу
20-30%. вони віддають Україні я можу ми
можемо довго говорити про приклади але
багато українська діаспора хоче
співпрацювати з Україною Наукова і
співпрацює у нас є приклади людей які
роблять аренді центри там і у нас да
Сьогодні будуть Ну і завтра будуть такі
представники бізнесу які це тобто
насправді якщо більш цілісно дивитися є
співпраця на рівні такому співавторства
на рівні обміну на рівні того що люди в
літо Влітку приїжджають там щось
викладають або пишуть статті разом і це
потрібно теж розвивати з часом ми будемо
як Китай коли будемо повертати масово
Але для цього потрібно створити умови
десь ми це починаємо робити це не 10
років назад але ну це шлях його треба
просто йти його треба здолати пам'ятаєте
Ще б хотілося б поговорити але це не
зараз це трошки пізніше проте наскільки
іноземним студентам цікаві наші
університети е-е скільки іноземців
хочуть вчитися в нас 10 секунд відповідь
навіть у нас До нас приїжджають
американці е аргентинці британці канадці
У нас є вчаться да тому що в нас є ці
викладачі топові Вони приїжджають ми є
сертифікат і такі місця є в Україні не
тільки різнорі тому приїжджають до нас І
це не тільки там якісь чисто професійна
історія люди приїжджають вчитися є таке
є таке але теж Ми можемо говорити про
масштаб дякую вам і далі я хочу
запросити до слова міністра освіти і
науки України Сергія шкарлика у вас
презентація Якщо вам Ні ну просто Якщо
вам зручніше ви можете тут е-е
презентацію І все добре все
дякую пані Оксана е-е знаєте
Тимофій дуже гарно сказав починати треба
з особистих прикладів почну перше маю
особистий приклад стосовно української
освіти і науки в світовому вимірі
стосовно того що де ж ми і в якому ми
статусі Сьогодні мені важко трошки
софіти б'ють але
в світовому вимірі академік Завгородній
академік лібанова Академіка місаренко я
в залі бачу може не всіх побачив
академік Пирожков
наші колеги ще ціла низка докторів
академік Кремінь докторів професорів які
сьогодні загально в світовому вимірі є
знаними і відомими професор мілеванов
пані Соломія вони сьогодні підключені
щодо стейкхолдерів в освіті в цілому 65%
в освіті в Україні 65% населення України
це стейкхолдери України мені Елла
маринівна не дасть збрехати Тому що
тільки 18 мільйонів батьків які долучені
до освітянського процесу це
закладів вищої освіти е-е стейкхолерів
разом мільйон 600 разом з студентів
викладачів всіх інших Це 4 мільйони
долучених школярів це майже
300 тисяч учнів
професійно-технічної освіти і ціла низка
наших громадян які без освіти в цілому
занурені в освітній процес те що китайці
відправляли так само як і ми 17%, але це
саме історія сьогоднішня яке
презентувався Президентський університет
17% лише повертались але ті хто
повертався творили такі Китай який ми
його бачимо зараз вони мають докласти
цих зусиль і в стратегії президентського
університету Це є вони мають докласти
всіх зусиль для того щоб позитивна
історія рухалася на тюнерство в державі
на віддачу здобутих знань в економіку
держави взагалі в суспільству і
формувати новий нову хвилю розвитку
нашої держави для того щоб вже завтра не
17:20 25 35 40% прийшли сюди Коли вони
прийдуть вони є вже носієм змін інших на
нових знаннях нових технологіях я
пишаюсь сьогодні Тіми всіми колегами які
долучились у нас дуже багато професорів
які побували Навчи в нас більше ніж 50
наших провідних стейходерів світу де
працюють і у відомі українці Які
навчилися за кордоном І сьогодні вони
долучені в рамках співпраці є
координаційна група міжнародної
міжнародної технічної допомоги є
секторальна робоча група разом з в
співпраці з нашими донорами з нашими
стейк холдерами всіма при цьому це
робота не тільки з урядом із
міністерством це робота взагалі всіх
стайхолдерів на цій платформі для того
щоб знаходити спільну мову освіта дуже
консервативна галузь
Враховуючи те що занурення в освіту
сьогодні вимагає і ми маємо скорегувати
свій свої очікування по результату 10
років на 12:15 от в цьому контексті
робота з провідними носіями освітніх
знань з провідними технологіями
освітньо- новітнього освітнього процесу
є для нас важливо чого сьогодні ті
університети сьогодні можуть в Україні в
Україні немає освіти ну це так
роздувають в Україні є 35-40 провідних
університетів Я не кажу що в цілому
повністю а є але є освітні програми
світовим світовим рівнем визнання
І до речі ну якби на останній колегії
коли доповідались про підготовку
іноземних студентів до того хто ж з нас
хто сюди їде їду з усіх країн звісно
більше їде тіх країн які з
пострадянського простіру там з певною
скульптурою з певним з певними освітніми
уставленими традиціями до цього але
прагнуть вони нового зовсім нового і ми
маємо концентрувати всю свою роботу з
нашими всіма стайколем А це й освітяни і
науковці і батьки і
бізнес-донори і міжнародні експерти всі
ті якщо ми хочемо щоб наша держава
рухалась то вона має спиратись на
світовий досвід має враховувати той Лах
запізнення Коли результати все ж таки
від освіти вийдуть і я вважаю що ми
спроможні на чолі з президентом на чолі
команди президента Саме генерувала ці
ідеї розвитку нової освітньої траєкторії
нового суспільного запиту на освіту і ми
його реалізуємо дякую вам
Дуже дякую вам можливо або зараз або
потім в мене таке запитання взагалі який
інструментарій впливу стейк холдерів на
забезпечення якості освітнього процесу в
Україні на сьогодні розпорядження
Кабінету Міністрів вже сформована новий
другий крок формування комісії
національної комісії з висвячення якості
освіти де 400 холдера є закордонні
експерти які є обов'язковим обов'язковою
командою відбіру тих колег які зайдуть
до складу національної агенції з питань
якості вищої освіти які оцінюють
спроможність формувати майбутні
результати освіти тому навіть навіть
така маленька е-е маленький внесок
закордонних стейкхолдерів здавалось би
ну
певна інституційна складова в освіті
національної агенція забезпечення якості
освіти але формують її за допомогою
міжнародних світових експертів
Дуже дякую вам і хочу сказати в
продовження вашого виступу що Ну це вже
камінь і великі провал телебачення і на
свій рахунок як те вважаю тому що така
кількість прав як академіків да А ми не
популяризуємо їх в наших ефірах для того
щоб молодь все більше і більше і більше
хотіла досягати таких самих вершин і
ставати та на виростати саме в науці
Я просто Поглянув директор національної
комісії з питань державної мови
професора Рися демська вона теж світовий
професор і вона сьогодні очолює цю
комісію пріс Вітаю вас Це вже Оплески
всім хто в нашій залі
так і я хочу сказати що ваші Оплески до
нас приєднався Сергій Бабак голова
комітету Верховної Ради України з питань
освіти науки та інновації Доброго ранку
пане Сергію
А зараз Я запрошую до виступу Анатолія
Загороднього президента Національної
академії наук України поговоримо про
унікальні українські кейси та досягнення
світового рівня
презентація буде не буде вам тут краще
[музика]
Доброго дня шановні пані і панове Вітаю
від імені Національної академії наук
України за
програмою формою я мав би розповісти вам
про про рівні наукові
досягнення світової науки і про
здобутки світового рівня українських
науковців є два слова
замість вступу світова наука бурхливо
розвивається
суспільство вкладає величезні кошти в її
розвиток і наука віддячує людству новими
знаннями про природу і суспільство і
особливо ваги набувають фундаментальні
дослідження і це підтверджують з тим що
якщо подивитися на результати
найважливіші наукові досягнення за
останні 10 років то ми побачимо серед
них саме
науково-фундаментальних результатів від
перших з них це відкриття бозону хікса -
це частинка яка
фактично
дозволила замкнути моделі
теорія елементарних частинок це
стандартна модель Так звана Вона описує
генерацію масою всіх елементарних
частинок це вкрай важлива вкрай важлива
відкриття далі редагування ДНК в тому
числі генома людини з метою
з метою запобігання генетичних хвороб
відкриття гравітаційних хвиль це дуже
фундаментальне відкриття передбаченого
ще багато років назад і Воно пов'язане
це неможливо осягнути просто так воно
пов'язано з тим що під дією гравітації
змінюється властивості простору далі е-е
про е-е поступ в розвитку штучного
інтелекту
відкриття нових екзопланет тобто планет
умови на яких близькі до земних умов А
можна відтак можна очікувати можна
очікувати е-е появи життя на таких
планетах безумовно
безумовно сюди варто додати ще і
здійснення посадки на е-е комету
тюрма вага герасиненка і
здійснена посадки на Марсі вивчення
дослідження Марса Марса годом
призером
Ну і виникає питання виникає питання де
ж на цих видатних відкриттів знаходиться
наука України можна почути від окремих
журналістів і так званих Вибачте
експертів що науки в Україні немає Я з
цим категорично не згоден більш того
попри всі труднощі нашого сьогодення
сіла ряду наукових напрямів Україна
посідає дуже місце серед провідних країн
світу а в ряді випадків в нас є навіть
лідери Ну і прикладом таким який
говорить підтверджує мої слова
є участю у створенні і здійснення
експериментів українських науковців на
великому адронному калайдері ви бачите
що це така е-е
такий дуже
досконалий інструмент для
дослідження зіткнення е-е
андронів тобто складовими з якого
складається атомне ядро довжина кільця
28 км на глибині 100 метрів частинки
прискорюються е-е до енергії 13 Терра
Електрон вольти це Шалені енергії в
результаті звітної народжуються багато
частинок І от е-е
реєструючи результати цих звітнень ми
бачимо ми бачимо що не з чого
складається хочемо дізнатися точніше і
дізнаємося от результати от ви бачите
е-е цей підземний тонель це на кшталт то
це тунеля метро е-е де є от власне труба
в якій відбувається з прискорення
заряджених частинок ця е система
знаходиться при клірендій температурі
взагалі Це одне з найвидатніших
технологічних рішень
цивілізації от побудова цього Великого
дранного колайдер так от результати
зіткнення реєструються реєструються
детекторами ну детектор це не якась там
маленька коробочка чи якийсь пристрій це
споруда величиною з
чотирьох-п'ятиповерховий будинок
начинена мікроелектронікою сенсорами і
так далі І от справи бачите детектор е-е
Аліса чи Аліса як його називають Ви
можете бачити що Україна е-е це офіційна
визнана Україна була присутня вона взяла
участь у створенні цього детектора це це
дуже високотел нагоріє технологічні
рішення наші науковці Там працюють на
парковці працюють і на інших детекторах
зокрема і на Детекторі CMS і там де був
відкритий базон фікса і широко виходять
сотня робіт е-е де наші українські
Колєги є співавторами видатних
чернігівських відкриттів ну і ще один
фермерське відкриття це ВНЗ зовсім
недавно 21-му році видання цену церкви
рієр написала про відкриття нової Квазі
частинки одерона яка була відкрита на
кінчику пера саме в Україні в інституті
теоретичної фізики імені боголюбава ще
один мегапроект міжнародний це проект
між е-е демонстраційного термоядерного
реактора ітер надзвичайно складна машина
теж дуже високого технологічні рішення
Україна на жаль не є членом цього
концерту Україна не здатна заплатити
гігантський членський внесок але завдяки
нашій участі в програмі дослідницькій
програмі є братом і входження в кон
наші науковці дуже щільно працюють в
цьому проекті І от ви бачите тут як
приклад українська проект з дослідження
початкової стадії розряду це вкрай
важлива Якраз для реалізації е-е проекту
Інтер в Харкові в Харківському
фізико-технічному інституті є абсолютно
унікальні установки яких немає ніде в
світі і на цих установках досліджувалась
е-е досліджували зіткнення
взаємодія плазми з стінками реактора і
без цього
Ну і термо будувався без цих досліджень
і термобудувався набагато довше ще одне
національне надбання України - Це
український радіотелескоп утр-2 це
рекордний телескоп І от такого подібного
нічого немає в світі
завдяки цьому телескопу зроблено дуже
багато відкриттів фундаментального
характеру але більше того цей радіотеле
включений в українську систему радіо
телескопів вона дістала назву
гігантської і українській е-е
радіотелескоп і подібного в світі теж
нічого немає і це той випадок коли не
Українські науковці їдуть кудись е-е
працювати на обладнанні
експериментальному а е-е
навпаки австрійські французькі колеги
приїздять в Харків на це На цей радіо
телескопні працюють там Ну і е цей
український гігантський радіотелескоп
стане складовою основною складовою вже
міжнародного радіотелескопа тобто
міжнародний співпраця йде дуже активна
ще одне унікальне унікальна установка це
під критична збірка джерело нейтронів
вона побудована за кошти отримані від
передачі збагаченого урану це
американські гроші власне ця е це
унікальна установка такої ніде немає в
світі вона на ній будуть досліджуватись
перше здійснюватися
контрольовані ланцюгові ядерні реакції з
тим щоби запобігати Тому що йому що ще
відбулося в Чорнобилі це контрольована
ланцюгова реакція це дослідження
трансмутації тобто
перетворення радіоактивних елементів
стабільні і нарешті виробництва
радіопрепаратів і я сподіваюсь ще
ближчим часом Коли це обстановка
запрацює то Україна буде мати власні
радіо fm-перферати а не імпортувати їх
за кордоном ще один унікальна розробка
це
магнетокардіограф е-е який набагато
безпечніший чим МРТ і кт чим і набагато
досконаліший Він використовує квантові
сенсори і Це розробка здійснена спільно
з оксфордшим університетом і наразі вже
один такий сканер використовується в
головному військовому госпіталі збройних
сил України Ще ще можна наводити дуже
багато прикладів
зокрема в інституті фізичної хімії
саржевського розроблені нові акумулятори
на основі нанокомпозитів вони за е-е
вони запатентовані в Сполучених Штатах в
Німеччині в Китаї і вже використовується
дуже широка корпорація для General
Motors тут ще один приклад - це
надпотужні
потужні
супер-конденсатори які вже закупила е-е
американські
аерокосмічне агентство які планується
використовувати і гібридному
автотранспорті і так далі І так далі все
це новітні розробки аналогів яких
практично немає в світі Ну і гордість
наших генетиків і селекціонерів це нові
сорти високо врожайні сорти зерна
пшениці які дають бачити до 140% з
гектару це унікально для України - це і
Варто сказати що цими сортами
засівається третина посівних площ під
е-е
культури і що кожна третя паляниця
випечена з сортів якраз з борошна
отриманого сортів зерна - це виведених в
цьому інституті Ну і наостанок це нові
нове досягнення це нові так звані
кольорові сорти зерна чому кольорові це
це не так цікаво чим вони кольорові а
біологічна цінність їх набагато вища ніж
звичайних звичайних сортів старта там
зерна Там набагато більше каратину і
інших мікроелементів це е-е це теж є
дуже такий блискучий блискучий результат
Ну теж про що я сказав це навіть не
верхівка айсберга навіть невертівська
айсберга це е це тільки невеличка
частина того де Українські науковці є на
світовому рівні і в окремих випадках і
перевищуються вони сказав от До речі
півматична установка джерело стане
основою
створення міжнародного центру бо я ще
раз повторюю такої установки немає ніде
в тобто я хочу сказати що наука України
була є і буде в неї є добрі перспективи
і наостанок що я чудово Я абсолютно
впевнений що е-е маючи політичну волю і
фінансову організаційно підтримку
президентської університет буде створено
в заплановані терміни але е-е формування
тематики науково-дослідних робіт
забезпечення сучасним обладнанням А
головне формування
наукових колективів світового рівня на
кафедрах університету Ну може взяти
певний час і національну Академія Наук
України готова в разі потреби надати
підтримку і кадрами і відкрити двері
лабораторій своїх інститутів для того
щоб студенти могли поєднувати освіту і
науку Дякую за увагу дякую справді
вражаюча доповідь стільки винаходів
стільки відкриття е-е єдине що Знаєте Я
хотіла б вас попросити Ми сподіваємось
що на наступний вже наш форум ви вже
будете в доповіді розказувати як
українські вчені винайшли ліки від
коронавірусу і ми врятували світ самі
українські вчені Ми на цьому шляху Ми на
цьому шляху чотири інститути вже
працюють над цією проблемою і ми от
дев'ятого червня на засіданні Президії
будемо обговорювати стан цієї проблеми я
вам користуючись нагодою зараз запросив
міністра охорони здоров'я Він обіцяв
бути і будемо працювати разом звісно
Дякую вам Дякуємо пане Анатолію а далі я
хочу запросити до слова лор Bill
заступницю голови представництва
дитячого фонду ООН в Україні поговоримо
про підтримку реформування українського
освіти
[музика]
Вітаю Шановні колеги для мене
превелика честь репрезентувати дитині
Шеф і ціна хочу дати вам погляд
міжнародній організації що працює в
Україні і підтримує освітніми
почули за надзвичайні успіхи української
науки і світлі цих успіхів треба
забезпечити
надійну основу освітнього для країни для
майбутнього процесу Я хотіла би
принагітну привітати Міністерство освіти
і уряд за їхніми
наполеглими зусиллями провести реформу
української школи
я бачу перший а випускники нової
української школи тепер
увійшли до освітнього циклу на
безперервно ми як міжнародні організації
збираємо досвід багатьох країн ми
намагаємось
сприяти поширенню міжнародних стандартів
для юнісеф Це
звісно ті речі що містяться в
міжнародній конвенції дитячих вправ як
організація Ми також розробляємо всілякі
стратегії і в освітньому
також маємо свої стратегії
глобальна стратегія
в чому суголосна із українського
урядовою стратегією освіти Отже ми
усьому світі пропагуємо рівнин на
приступ до
мого навчатися поліпшення навичок для
кожного І також
за
звичайних обставин і в контексті
вразливому оці всі три компоненти Ми
вбачаємо також і вам
український урядовій програмі у нас сама
опікується різні директора та чи
дирекції реформа українська поступає лак
Ми всі знаємо
торік мали надзвичайні обставини
пов'язані з пандемією
також на освітній освітню галузь
поглибивши нерівність
А це стане і ми маємо забезпечити те що
реформа розвивалась таким чином щоб
усунути чи принаймні пом'якшити ці нові
не бажані явища наприклад Так звана
інклюзивна чи включно освіта
процес навчання учіння треба забезпечити
те щоб усі діти мали приступи до якісної
освіти коли я кажу всі діти я маю на
увазі діти з інвалідністю діти що
походять із вразливих родин тих що
живуть у зоні конфлікту це дуже важливо
для юнісеф забезпечити те щоб нова
українська школа українська шкільна
реформа
підкреслювала інклюзивність чи
включність освіти на цьому Дозвольте
мені зупинитися і
я поділася з вами баченням міжнародної
організації в цій галузі освіти галузі
Ми радо Працюємо з міністерством освіти
з усіма директоратами цього Міністерства
і з нами намір продовжувати Я хочу
запросити до слова лісу лялі до
керівництву напрямку освіти науки офісу
президента України Аліса хотіла щоб
поговорити з вами про перехід до
генерування власних моделей розвитку і
підтримку талантів
дякую Я мабуть як
попередні гості почну з
особистої історії ну в плані ми почули
що в нас грандіозні плани ми знаємо що
ми маємо підтримку і міжнародних
інституцій і міжнародних партнерів
реалізації цих планів але я власне хочу
сказати про те що
дуже круто що ми маємо велику
консолідацію зусиль у реалізації цих
планів для мене таким першим
найближчим прикладом стала наприклад
ініціативи президента яка була минулого
року це всеукраїнська школа онлайн
яка Буквально за декілька тижнів з ідеї
перетворилася на
практичний реалізований продукт і яка
допомогла
яка Допомогла дітям отримувати знання в
період карантину коли ми стикнулися з
тим що ми взагалі не знали чого Що
робити І ця ідея змогла з'явитися ця
ідея змогла реалізуватися і змогла
знайти своє продовження удосконалення і
перетворення у сучасний
повноцінний окремий продукт і платформа
всеукраїнська школа онлайн лише завдяки
консолідації зусиль і я думаю що якщо ми
будемо продовжувати
рухатися в напрямі консолідації
об'єднання зусиль то
всі наші плани реалізуються набагато
швидше і набагато краще ніж навіть з
ближньою перспективи це виглядає
і ще декілька слів про те що
завдяки отакій консолідації зусиль ми
маємо дуже
круті і дуже потужні проекти які я
впевнена вже завтра можна буде почути
трохи більше подробиць але зрештою можна
анонсувати і президент про це сьогодні
говорив
Володимир Олександрович заклав
ініціативу з підтримки
дітей які складають ЗНО
дітей які виграють міжнародні конкурси
олімпіади зрештою з підтримки
талановитих дітей
ця ініціатива буде трошки більше
розкрита завтра але це дуже хороша річ
яка я впевнена призведе до того що ми
все більше зможемо
пишатися тим що маємо і
молоді науковці будуть додаватися і
додавати в ту копілку
наших досягнень про яку Анатолій
глібович нам розповідав
Я дуже дякую і я сподіваюсь що що в мене
далі зможемо так само
продуктивною злагоджено виконувати наші
наші задачі Дякую пане дякую пані Аліса
я хотіла сказати що підтримувати дітей
талановитих І звісно вчителів
талановитих тому що мені як мамі дітей
саме показав оце всеукраїнська школа
онлайн показала Наскільки в нас багато є
талановитих вчителів тому що Ну
насправді Я в захваті була від багатьох
українська мова англійська мова
математика Це було дійсно цікаво Це було
дуже навчально і діти хотіли навчатися
здавалося перед телевізором Так але вони
хотіли навчатись і насправді
зрештою Мені здається дуже важливо в
тому всьому зважити що це були дуже
короткі терміни і це був чистий
абсолютний ентузіазм педагогів це
вчителі не просто от високопрофе як люди
які знають там свій предмет які знають
педагогічні методики це люди які
згодилися витрачати на це ну по 20% на
добу аби дати дітям можливість
продовжувати якісно здобувати освіту це
фантастика так вони це Діли там майже
цілий день на зйомках тому що я теж
приймала участь і вони там не 2 години
на добувати щоб 24 майже от зараз
поговоримо про якість освіти українське
ми поговоримо з Руслан Гурак запрошую до
слова голова державної служби якості
освіти України а саме в темі міжнародної
співпраці задля покращення якості освіти
та залучення українського досвіду за
кордон
Дякую
ви знаєте Я уважно слухаючи всіх
спікерів пригадався мені іспанський
філософ Хосе ортега і гессет який власне
у своїй праці місія в університету
зробив висновок що кожна країна будує ту
систему освіти яка притаманна власне
кращим традиціям цієї країни
і
принагідно задаю собі запитання і ми з
колегами давно рефлексуємось цього
приводу А чи вдалося нам збудувати
ту систему освіти яка уже зараз
притаманна розвитку і кращим традиціями
України бо вже ми маємо 30-річчя
незалежності України і ви знаєте можу
говорити виключно в частині моніторингу
і виключно в частині розуміння А що
відбувається з якістю освіти і в тому
числі і хотів би поговорити про середню
освіту
і коли ми подивилися і переоцінили всю
систему ми побачили що традиційно у нас
залишалася система оцінки якості через
оцінку порушень чинного законодавства у
сфері освіти
і ця система нічого не давала
жодного успішного прикладу оцінки
найкращих систем шкільних ми не могли
оцінити тому власне
ми змінили цей підходи і нам дав
можливість закон України про освіту
побудувати абсолютно іншу систему
оцінювання якості і забезпечення якості
через суб'єктність і через спроможність
кожної школи
робити кращі ті процеси які їм
притаманні І власне тут дуже було
важливо
побачити чи ми маємо будувати самі по
собі цю систему чи ми маємо бути
частинкою освітнього простору
зокрема європейського освітнього
простору і
нещодавно 18 лютого в Європейському
Союзі була прийнята резолюція щодо
стратегічних рамок співробітництва у
сфері освіти і підготовки не тільки
європейського простору а й поза ним так
цей документи називається
і першою стратегічною вимогою є
поліпшення якості і справедливості для
успіху кожного
і ви знаєте в Європейському Союзі
питання якості визначають як питання
засвоєння ключових компетенцій для
успіху і через підтримку
педагогічного персоналу
державна служба якості освіти два місяці
назад провела опитування як розуміють
якість освіти наші батьки учні вчителі
директори шкіл і більшість респондентів
показали що ми так само розуміємо якість
освіти як і в Європейському просторі
І власне оцих 5 стратегічних напрямів
які є другий з них Це є
безперервність освіти впродовж життя і
тут дуже добре би використати нам в тому
числі і перепакувати так нашу систему
щоб ми могли використати ті цілі і
індикатори які є в Європейському
просторі і є в європейській системі для
того щоб бути частинкою і мати розуміння
як ми працюємо над вирішенням тих
завдань і тих базових потреб які є в
шкільних системах
державна служба якості освіти
розбудовуючи внутрішню систему
забезпечення якості кожної школи ми мали
дуже Хороших і унікальних партнерів це
зокрема Чехія
голландці
і шотландці оце наших три ключових
партнери яким ми з якими ми спільно
будували
і впроваджували в життя саме підходи до
інституційного аудиту до виміру тих
процесів які закладені в школі і
сьогодні я мушу сказати що ми пішли
трішки дальше І ми вибудували таку
систему самооцінювання школи шкіл яку ми
запроваджуємо до речі з 1 вересня цього
року а це абсолютний софт система яка
дасть можливість кожній школі оцінити
себе самій не чекаючи коли держава
прийде
до них в гості
І власне наші партнери з Чехії оцінивши
наш продукт беруть собі теж за основу цю
розробку і теж намагається впроваджувати
вже в життя це свідчить про одне що ми
маємо дуже класні здобутки і ми маємо
хороші напрацювання в сфері забезпечення
якості І тільки нам потрібно постійно
звірювати годинники і не йти самим по
цьому шляху тернистому а мати постійно
комунікацію з нашими європейськими
партнерами і не тільки європейськими
задля розвитку
нашої системи освіти
і зокрема Я б хотів повернутися ще до
одного до однієї цілі - Це третя
стратегічний план в цій частині це
розвиток педагогічних кадрів
ми маємо унікальні
традиції в підготовці наших вчителів ми
маємо прекрасних вчителів Але маємо теж
ті ж самі проблеми що її в Європейському
Союзі
середній вік вчителя зростає
Молодь не дуже переконливо і де до
роботи в школу тому тут нам ще потрібно
переглянути не тільки питання оцінювання
роботи вчителя через атестацію
сертифікацію
чи інші підходи а й очевидно нам треба
буде суттєво переглянути питання
підвищення кваліфікації і професійний і
підтримки професійного розвитку кожного
вчителя тому ми знаємо це ми над цим
працюємо і зараз спільно з міністерством
освіти і науки України ми готуємо нові
документи які би могли переоцінити і
переосмислити професійний розвиток
вчителя керівника і директора школи дуже
вам дякую пане Руслан і зараз до слова Я
запрошую Сергія бабака голову комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти
науки та інновацій і поговоримо про
законодавчу підтримку реформування
освіти і науки України ви єдине що
вибачте пана Сергію в нас небагато часу
лишилося ще два спікера ви і Соломія
тому якщо можна спробую коротко Мені
дуже тішить що ми говоримо про
українську освіту і науку у світовому
вимірі Це справді дуже важливо Але для
того щоб це сталося І сталося ефективно
нам потрібно зробити звернути увагу
Скажімо так на декілька речей перше - Це
так зване взаємне взаємне опилювання да
або обмін досвідом або перенесення
найкращих практик і в даному випадку вже
зроблені перші кроки бо дуже важливо
відправляти українських студентів
найкращий університети світу і звичайно
ініціатива президента зі стипендіями для
талановитих дітей які поїдуть навчатися
за кордон це дуже важливо навіть якщо
частина з них не повернеться більше все
одно повер дивіться я вам з власного
досвіду якщо ми вже ділимося власним
досвідом скажу що я закінчував в
університет в Британії і повернувся сюди
20 років тому Мані краплі не жалкую і це
справді новий досвід нове бачення і
кожен з нас має можливість його потім
втілювати Тут друга важлива річ - це
уряд дозволив або скажімо Так Ми зробили
це законом спростили а уряд своєю
постанови ще більше спростив
доступіноземних університетів на
території України Ми сподіваємося що це
будуть якісні університети над цим
працює уряд і Міністерства і сподіваюсь
що найближчим часом вони в Україні
з'являться це підвищать конкуренцію
всередині освітньої системи а значить
підніметь рівень якості освіти Але разом
з тим Я думаю що треба дозволити це вже
не питання Я думаю Верховної Ради Але
якщо це стосується Верховної Ради ми
готові підтримати ці ініціативи уряду це
спрощення
залучені іноземних фахівців іноземних
фахівців в університеті і в науковій
устано це дуже важливий момент в них є
проблеми з реєстрацією певні ускладнення
є проблеми з оподаткуванням є взагалі
проблеми з влаштуванням на роботу і це
зокрема стосується і нормативів певних
Міністерства і так далі тому я знаю що
уряд над цим працює сподіваюсь що
найближчим часом це буде е-е і у нас
зроблено другий важливий момент для того
щоб ми були конкурентоспроможними у
світі нам потрібно створювати потужні
освітні наукові осередки в Україні одним
з перших кроків півтори години тому тут
президент України підписав указ про
створення президентського університету
Ми дуже сподіваємося що це справді стане
е-е чи він стане флагманом української
освіти і покаже абсолютно нову якість
підготовки фахівців І взагалі абсолютно
новий підхід до роботи Але разом з тим Я
вважаю що нам потрібно створювати і
серед українських університетів
величезні регіональні і потужні галузеві
університети зокрема шляхом об'єднання і
це дуже важливий елемент в нас на жаль
цей процес по суті заблокований указом
Президента від 98-го року яким не
дозволяється об'єднувати майно
національних університетів А в нас їх
під 200 більше ніж 160 здається
національних університетів Це велика
проблема Ми домовились про те що ми
вирішимо її законом і сподіваюся вже він
на дру- на другому читанні найближчими
двома пленарними тижнями ми приймемо Той
закон який дозволяє об'єднувати
університети в більш потужні бо тільки
великі університети потужні з гарною
матеріальної фінансової базою можуть
дати хорошу якість освіти третій елемент
- це експансія власне нашої Української
освіти і науки на зовнішні ринки це дуже
важливий момент в Україні зараз
навчається більше ніж 70 000 іноземних
студентів але є певні обмеження які
введені законом зокрема зараз є
ініціатива комітету освіти і науки ми її
найближчими тижнями сподіваємося
Будемо вносити в парламент для того щоб
наші університети могли зробити такий
певний квантовий стрибок на зовнішній
ринки Ми хочемо зараз в нас на жаль Ну
на мою думку особисто на жаль навчання
іноземців дозволено лише двома мовами
українською або Англійською ми втрачаємо
величезні ринки наших сусідів
мова йде про те щоби дозволити навчання
іноземців в окремих групах іноземців
будь-якою мовою
університет на Волині або у Львові
можуть це робити польською мовою і
Забирати їх студентів до нас а не
віддавати наших студентів туди в
Закарпатті навчати угорською мовою в
Чернівцях
румунською мовою в Одесі болгарською
мовою врешті-решт в Харкові російською
мовою Ми порахували дуже приблизно що
цей потенціал цього закону - це плюс 20
тисяч студентів іноземців а це означає
що щорічно це плюс один і дві десятих
мільярди як мінімум гривень в бюджети
власне в університеті і щорічно +4 млрд
грн бюджет місцевих громад і це щорічно
Уявіть собі Який обсяг шалених коштів
якщо держава не може в повному обсязі
дати настільки багато грошей в
університетам скільки вони хочуть то не
треба хоча б дати їм можливість
заробляти і не заважати їм бо відверто
кажучи посли цих країн які приїжджають
до нас Вони просто Кажуть дивіться в нас
особливо в країнах Середньої Азії ну В
нас кажуть і старі- історично Вони
знають російську мову і тому в нас
питання Коли ми не можемо відправити до
вас навчатися російською то не
ображаєтеся але ми його в правому в
Росію і Білорусію то що ж ми під гру
під- підіграємо цим країнам Наша задача
забрати в них оцей шматок економічного
пирога це дуже важливий момент тому ми
зараз активізуємо роботу із
міністерством освіти і знаю що в них є
потужні ініціативи щодо залучення
іноземних студентів нашої на продажу
скажімо експорту наших освітніх послуг
Ну і четвертий момент на якому що
зупинитися не буде потужної вищої освіти
якщо в університетах не буде науки ми
вже не говоримо про наукові установи де
наука є
мега основним видом діяльності а для
того щоб була гарна наука нам потрібна і
підтримувати науковців молодих науковців
зокрема і для цього є і стипендії
Верховної Ради і стипендії президента
Але разом з тим дати треба можливість
отримати найкраще обладнання яке можна
отримати для того щоб на ньому
продукувати найкращі результати дуже
важко Я знаю що наша і національна
Академії наук і галузеві академії і
національний фонд досліджень фінансують
шикарні проекти наші команди науковців
роблять справді феноменальні речі навіть
на тому обладнанні які є а тепер я вам
по собі що ми їм ще дамо можливість
отримати найкраще обладнання ми до Дня
науки ми так вже сталося щодо Дня науки
зареєстрували комітетом пакет законів
який звільняє від в'їзного мита і
оподаткування обладнання для
університетів і наукових установ власне
саме наукове обладнання регенти запасні
єдиний і так далі в момент ввезення
більше того ми хочемо вивести оцей
закупівлю реагентів і запасних частин
з-підпрозоро взагалі з-під дії прозоро
чому Тому що якщо ти купив обладнання
однієї фірми ти не можеш купити до нього
реагенти іншої фірми і тут просто втрата
від трьох до шести місяців вона
закупівлю цих реагентів це насправді
безглуздя і ми комітетом хочемо цю
історію виправити ну і з міністерством
освіти з Кабінетом міністрів ми е-е
справді хочемо наступного року ще
започаткувати декілька субвенцій які б в
окремо підтримували наукові об'єкти що
становлять національне надбання і давали
додаткові капітальні ви е-е капітальні
витрати для наукових установ і
університетів власне на закупівлю
наукового обладнання Я думаю що без
цього нам буде дуже важко Ми намагаємося
розвиватися і так але менше з тим Я
думаю що при прийнятті цих законів це
значно спростить нам життя е-е Ми
чекаємо на наступні ініціативи від
кабінету міністрів готовий Верховною
Радою зокрема комітетом освіти і науки
підтримувати їх всі і робити таким чином
щоб наша освіта і наука на всіх рівнях
була конкурентоспроможною в світі і щоб
до нас їхало дітей більше ніж від нас
їдуть за кордон Дуже дякую вам дуже
дякую І зараз я хочу запросити до слова
Соломія Шпак головний експертко
Департаменту фінансової стабільності НБУ
професорку Київської школи економіки і
вона якраз розкаже про успішний кейс
української вченої яка поїхала на захід
і повернулася
Доброго дня шановні колеги і учасники
форуму Україна 30 перш за все дуже дякую
за запрошення до такої важливої сесії
про українську освіту та науку в
світовому вимірі Мені дуже було приємно
почути про всі ваші і особисті історії і
плани на майбутнє щодо розвитку освіти і
науки в Україні
Минулого року я здобула ступінь phd в
університеті Джорджа Мейсона в США по
спеціальності публічна політика
перш ніж вступити на докторську програму
США я навчалась на магістерській
програмі Київської школи економіки бо я
зараз працюю професоркою одночасно
займаючись дослідженнями Національного
банку України
перш за все Я б хотіла повернутися до
нас до нашої сесії власне вона звучить
як освіта і наука у світовому вимірі
після семи років навчання на докторській
програмі та занурення у літературу
спілкування з науковцями цього світу та
працюючи в співавторстві з деякими з них
я можу впевнено сказати що немає іншої
науки ніж наука у світовому вимірі
згадував Тимофій у науки немає
географічних кордонів
якісні науці не важливо Чи це є автором
з Америки Німеччина чи України
світовий науці важлива якість своїх
досліджень яка зокрема в економіці і
публічній політиці грунтується на двох
китах
перше - це розуміння проблеми і
контексту якоїсь досліджуєш
і друге - це бездоганне володіння
методами дослідження
взаємодія цих двох котів може пояснити
чому ж після скількох років навчання у
США Я з радістю повернулася в Україну
дістаю неймовірне задоволення від роботи
тут
щодо першого розуміння проблематики
важливо зазначити що оскільки моя сфера
публічна Політика це сфера Наукова але
також є прикладна і оці сфері важливо
розуміння проблем дослідження зокрема
які саме проблеми публічної політики
вимагають нагального вирішення це зараз
науковий аналіз найбільш доцільний
робота в Україні цікава тим що тут існує
середовище для розуміння тих проблем
будучи тут я як науковець маю швидкий
досвід в експертів з усіх питань які
мені цікаво досліджувати ці експерти
працюють зі мною поруч в Національному
банку України в київській школі
економіки в аналітичних центрах
громадських організаціях це люди
фахівців своїх сферах і можуть допомогти
зрозуміти реальні проблеми для науки
набагато швидше ніж би науковець
пробував ідентифікувати його їх десь у
Вашингтоні
в Україні також існує неймовірна
кількість відкритих даних яких щороку
стає все більше і більше які можна
використовувати для вирішення цих
проблем на основі наукового аналізу
щодо другого кита власне методів
дослідження навчання на докторській
програмі дало мені згрунтовно базу та
знання інструментарію
повернувшись Вашингтону Я також маю
широку мережу співавторів та колег в
університетах по всьому світу робота з
якимись спонукає мене бути в курсі
найактуальніших досліджень моїй сфері
будучи в Україні моїм колегам цікаво
продовжуватись попрацювати зі мною адже
Окрім цих теоретичних знань Я тепер
мають до всього доступ до всього що може
робота в Україні запропонувати власне я
слугую такою ланкою між науковцями там і
проблемами тут і Моя освіта здобутала
США виступає маркером довіри доменник
В нас просто дуже піджимає вже часто
тому якщо можливо
змістовно грунтовно і коротенько
Так я якраз власне хотіла сказати що на
мені це все не замикається коло так
окрім викладання ми активно залучаємо
наших студентів організовуючи
академічний семінари де Ми запрошуємо
науковців стоп університетів світу наші
студенти мають прямий доступ до них наші
викладачі мають прямий доступ до них е-е
і е-е власне коли я думала коли в
останній рік навчання мала можливість
прийняти пропозиції роботи в інших
університетів в Європі я довго зважувала
звертатись до України чи ні Але після
цього одного року викладання і
дослідження Україні
Це відчуття що це дотичні до розвитку
України через освіту воно мене
переконала що я зробила правильний вибір
і викладаючи тут я можу
забезпечити те що не тільки Західна
освіта але українська освіта будуть в
майбутньому маркерами довіри до
Я дуже дякую вам дякую пані Соломія я
хочу сказати всім що вибачте але всі
свої питання ви зможете завдати вже в
кулуарах нашого форуму тому що наступна
панель вже чекає на вас і я знаю мені
організатори сказали що Останнє слово я
передаю вам так Міністр освіти і науки
України Сергій шкарлет
Шановні колеги Шановні освітяни шановні
науковці ми сьогодні маємо честь за
дорученням президента презентувати
офіційний макет президентського
університету який розташований в холі Є
пропозиція всі зацікавлених пройти туди
подивитись формацію об'єкту отримати
певні відповіді на запитання всім
освітянами науковцям на чолі такі гарних
прикладів як
професор мілеванов який повернувся з
Америки професор Бабак який повернувся
Шотландії пані Соломії як повернулась з
Вашингтону ми маємо позитивні приклади і
кейси Я вірю що наша освіта буде
розвиватись дякую вам
[оплески]
дуже цікаво змістовно дискусію справді
за мить ми вже готові надати слово
міністру в нашій експозонії для
презентації а потім ще буде
прес-конференція
учасників наших обговорень де журналісти
зможуть поставити запитання
в цілому враховуючи актуальність
особистість основних напрямів які
президент заклав як професію майбутнього
як професії шостого технологічного
вкладу шостої хвилі новації саме
концепція президентського університету
була побудована на е-е одному замкнутому
просторі це навединг побудований на 16
гектарах землі з загальною
загальною комунікацією всіх корпусів це
і біологічні цей біотехнології і
екологія людини це і нанотехнології
аерокосмічні технології інформаційні
технології кібербезпека і штучний
інтелект це е-е і апарт-готель для
викладачів та студентів це парт це
центральний адміністративний корпус це
клінічна лікарня яка обов'язково має
бути залучена і як елемент соціальної
гарантій і елемент дослідження е-е по
програмі біотехнології та екології
людини дипломатична служба та і офіси
іноземних компаній в цілому в рамках
ідеї президента України Міністерство
освіти і науки формувало певну концепцію
щодо розвитку цього університету і
заступник міністра освіти і науки Ігор
Миколайович гербарук якраз є керівником
цієї робочої групи і керівником цього
проекту разом з нашими провідними
архітекторами разом з
цілою низкою
зацікавлених і ідейно зацікавлених осіб
в цьому проекті формували велику велику
ідею Президента щодо створення нової
університету майбутнього Я хочу передати
слово пану ігорюку для
взагалі промоушена стосовно
цієї ідеології президентського
університету Дякую Сергій Миколайович
колеги Ну по-перше за все Я хочу сказати
величезні слова вдячні президенти
України за ту ідею які яку він надав ми
на сьогоднішній день презентуємо вже
якийсь перший результат реалізації цієї
ідеї але розумієте що ні одна ідея вона
не відбувається без колективної роботи а
саме тому хочу щиро подякувати всім
своїм колегам з Міністерства освіти і
науки а з інших міністерств міністерств
зброю та трансформації держспецзв'язку
Міністерства охорони здоров'я і так далі
і тому подібне Ну але найбільше всього я
хочу подякувати тим хто долучився до
створення архітектурних концепцій Чому
тому що насправді це вже як кажуть
вінець в тих архітектурних концепцій які
всі були а до цього були долучені і
студенти Київського національного
університету будівництва архітектури
інших компаній і в даному випадку я хочу
особисто подякувати а-а Віталію молочко
і п Борису шкрогелю з богдановського за
те що вони створили такий прекрасний
університет таку Прекрасну концепцію
саме для нас дуже важливо край важлива
щоб студенти які прийдуть в цей
університет вони як сьогодні вже казав
Сергій Миколайович е були не просто
будівниками майбутнього а щоб вони були
архітекторами майбутнього успішної
України саме тому для нас є дуже-дуже
важливим
готові до відповіді
Да будь ласка
[оплески]
в Україні є елемент експертних продукти
в частности среди наших продуктов
например джиджит самий крупная доска
объявлений в Африке А очень большой
бизнес батерми один из крупнейших
приложений для
спорта и здоровья в мире мой большое
количество других бизнессов в частности
именно расскажет про кейки у нас
достаточно большой аниционный фонд
который вкладывает в проекты носить
стадии с точки зрения образования хочу
затронуть три темы первое - Это наша
работа с университетами очень много
действительно вкладываем совместную
работу с университетами вторая Ведь это
наша собственные эти программы которая
мы проводим больше степени как программы
для всего рынка у нас Я считаю самая
Разбитая система вот таких вот эти школ
в год на них хапается 20 000 человек
нескольсок человек проходит Ну и третья
мы самый крупный инвестор в Украине
который вкладывается в компании которые
работают системное образования на
экспортные рынке внутри Украины вот про
це продуктова компанія в екосистемі
Genesis яка займається створенням і
розвитку мобільних продуктів для
дошкільнят тому фактично я і займаюся
світу і дошкільнята це перша ступінь
взагалі освіти будь-якої людини
Дякую
всім привіт мене звати Роман Апостол я
сію та співзасновник компанії My Talking
Я дуже велику частину свого життя
присвятив навчанню вчився з 5 років вчив
багато математику їздив на міжнародну
Олімпіаду з математики після цього
вчився в хорошому університеті в
Шевченка і
чотири з половиною роки працював в
Google в нью-йорку Зараз я в Україні я
розумію наскільки важлива освіта і я
хочу щоб люди з будь-якого кутка України
мали доступ до класної освіти в мене
свого часу цей був доступ тому що я
вчився в класному ліцеї при університеті
Шевченка потім в університеті Шевченка І
зараз ми даємо цю можливість будь-кому з
будь-якої частини України А минулого
року до нас подали більше 60 тисяч людей
на навчання і Загалом ми влаштували на
роботу більше тисячі людей в галузі айті
Дякую Привіт всім Мене звати Єгор в
ліва частина від центральної будівлі зі
шпильом ліва частина 16 гектарів чому
саме на вднг є концепція сьогодні
формування нового простіру вднг Де є і
бізнес-зона і спортивна зона її зона
культури і відпочинку і в цілому
розвиток президентського університету
разом з біокластером біоклінікою є
логічним завершенням просторового
розвитку території вднг для того щоб
студенти мали можливість користуватись
всіма об'єктами інфраструктури одночасно
і до речі залучення бізнесу ідея
державного приватного партнерства і
залучення бізнесу в
процес
розвитку цього президентського
університету є ключовою ідеєю і вона
якраз на
поруч із бізнес майданчиком вона дуже
гарно має реалізуватися в цілому по
першим ще техніко-економічного об
питання досконале воно не розроблялось
але оцей концепт разом з первинним
первинно необхідною кількістю обладнання
під ті чи інші цілі які поставлені по 6
стратегічних напрямах розвитку освітніх
напрямах
сам університет - це приблизно 6,7 млрд
гривень на 3 роки це нове будівництво
абсолютно нова історія це перше
наближення Але разом з підготовкою разом
з проектним офісом разом з
проектно-кошторисною документацією 7,2
так десь 7,2 млрд грн на 3 роки
Дякую за запитання будь ласка
в чому проблема якщо не справляються ну
майже будуємо саме для України
дійсно в цьому світі в цьому світі є
такі напрями Це ті популярні напрями які
сьогодні є в цьому світі і формують
майбутнє і розвитку науки і технології
це лише такі нарисні напрямки вони
можуть через два роки змінити зовсім
ідея я трошки не зовсім зрозумів ваше
запитання запитання в тому що можна
запросити людей з іншого світу в Україну
або готувати там
Я маю на увазі що в Україні немає схожих
напрямків по інших університетах саме
мова про інші університети сьогодні є Ну
по-перше якщо враховувати те що буде
зовсім нова взагалі законодавчі
підґрунтя розвитку цього університету
буде принаймні трирічний бакалаврат буде
принаймні принаймні концентрація це так
званий внутрішній український раз мозку
коли всі провідні науковці або викладачі
які будуть спроможні нести знання на
розвиток на кращий розвиток саме цього
наукового напрямку будуть концентровані
в одному в одному приміщенні в одній
локації наприклад ну на сьогодні
бакалаврат з it-технології - це від 35
до 42 дисциплін але не по кожній з них
не по кожній з цих напрямів працюють
кращі фахівці в Львівській політехніки
Це одні один набір фахівців Київський
політехніці інші Дніпровські інші в
Одеській і інші національності Шевченка
є свої фахівці а тут буде широкий
конкурс і оголошення саме концентрація
мізків на підготовку саме цього
проектного напрямку дякую
[музика]
іспити чи буде гуртожиток в університеті
максимально Практично за запитання
мабуть ви не були на центральний
презентації макету тому що там дійсно є
є навіть вже визначення будівлі під
апарт-готель і працівників
науково-педагогічної персонал так так ну
ви та Вибачте Нічого там можна буде
подивитися Парк Готель для студентів для
осіб які навчаються а щодо нагадайте
будь ласка вступ вступ я вже сказав про
окремо взагалі окремий законодавчу
підґрунті ЗНО є базовим але на ЗНО не
буде ні в якому випадку обмежуватись
набір Бо це буде звичайно університет
в цій частині відбір буде відбиватись ну
відбуватись принаймні в чотири етапи де
будуть світові закордонні експерти які
мають можливість ЗНО - це лише допуск
після цього детальні співбесіди щодо
майбутньої спроможності цієї людини
працювати і давати і генерувати нові
знання
будь ласка бюджет чи контрактна форма
виключно бюджет поки розмова іде
виключно на бюджет тому що ми
максимальну кількість людей за кожним з
освітніх напрямків а їх 6 плануємо не
більше 20
питанням та викладачами Скажіть будь
ласка з яких надходжень це буде
здійснено
саму університеті ілі взагалі по державі
взагалі це державний бюджет державного
бюджету України вчителі і викладачі це
виключно державного бюджету якщо
контрактна форма навчання то там тоді з
коштів юридичних і фізичних осіб
процедура стандартна воно нічого не
змінюється
А чому не вистачає Звідки у вас така
інформація
так не вистачає чи зарплата залишається
на 20 а в кінці року на 30%, яка буде
збільшена щось у вас неперевірені дані
вибачте
чи може
багато цієї інформації якщо є додатково
дивіться
А чи є ще запитання
я бачила що в принципі кожен може та
додати щось до цієї теми давайте з вас
розпочнемо і просто враження очікування
насправді
просто хочу дійсно додати там те що
Сергій Миколайович казав з приводу
університету
ми пропонуємо
принципово іншу
індивідуалізовану матрицю навчання Чому
тому що насправді оця матриця
нашарування накопичення знань вона на
сьогоднішній день достатньо часто
пробуксовує саме тому ми взяли оце
триєдине начало розвиток особистості
розвиток професіонала і розвиток
стратегічного напрямку
це всеукраїнський форум Україна 30
освіта і наука далі переходимо до дуже
важливої такого Фактора розвитку освіти
і науки у сучасному просторі це
цифровізація цієї галузі я передаю слово
мудратору дискусії експерту з інновацій
з інвестицій і стартапів Міністерства
цифрової трансформації України Антону
мельнику який вже далі поведе розмову із
експертами які вже на сцені форуму
Україна 30
дуже Дякую дорогі друзі Сьогодні
дуже важлива і цікава тема це
цифровізація освіти
я на правах модератора зараз поставлю
наших шановних експертів і зроблю потім
невеличкий вступ
розповім про те що сьогодні дуже
важливий для України сьогодні в нас
присутні Артур селецький заступник
міністра освіти і науки України з питань
це твого розвитку
Дмитро Завгородній радник заступника
міністра цифрової трансформації України
[оплески]
Анна Сидорчук операційна директорка
освіторій
вітання
Вадим карадій директор українського
інституту розвитку освіти
Михайло Поплавський
ректор Київського національного
університету культури і мистецтв
також сьогодні з нами онлайн будуть
присутні Сергій колибошин заступник
голови комітету Верховної Ради України з
питань освіти і інновацій
і також онлайн Сьогодні у нас наш гість
з Естонії таміл керес керівник і cool
онлайн-платформи
[оплески]
Отже
ми розуміємо що зараз цифрова
цифровізація освіти дуже важлива в наш
час в історію яка трапилась Минулого
року з пандемією коронавірусу ми
розуміємо що технології пришвидшили всі
процеси які давно відкладались я скажу
що позавчора був на дуже цікавий події і
неймовірні події це була Всеукраїнська
олімпіада з робототехніки де були
маленькі дітки програмували роботів і це
неймовірне явище коли вогонь в очах цих
дітей які вже є талантами Та це не
просто користувачі
новітніх технологій це не просто
користувачі там скажем планшетів в люди
які ми вміють грати і користуватися тими
пристроями Які в нас є це талант який
вже твориться інові технології
я скажу що я маю також дотичне скажем
відношення до освіти тому що я взагалі
але в 2015 році Разом з друзями заснував
некомерційну Академію кодування де ми
навчаємо діток 8-10 років кодування і
вже навчили понад 20 містах України
близько 2000 дітей і для чого ми це
зробили чому ми це зробили
тому що я навчався також колись на
програмування на початку в Київському
технікуму технікумі електронних приладів
потім в університеті я скажу що з нашої
групи яка навчалася в технікумі з 30
дітей студентів продовжили дальше
займатись в it і працювати двоє людей це
я і мій товариш всі інші вирішили
змінити свою професію Саме через те що
така модель навчання була вже не цікава
вона була для студентів вона скажем
додавала там е-е більше напруги ніж
зацікавленості і ми з друзями вирішили
що так ми вже там займались уже скажімо
власного бізнесами що треба зробити
якусь корисну річ і спробувати знайти
талантів А найкраще знаходити талантів І
взагалі найкраще давати можливість
обирати професію ще в маленькому віці
дітям і е-е скажу що так як ми навчаємо
дітей у нас е-е взагалі там по 10 дітей
в групі більше половини дітей Зазвичай
це нашою статистикою це ми знаходимо
таланти які одразу вже розуміють що
кодування - це їх це це це їхнє майбутнє
вони хочуть цим займатись вже з
маленького віку їм не потрібно там дуже
велика історія навчання в школі коли
вони тільки в 11-му класі починають
думати Куди вони хочуть чим займатись
вони вже знають Це з маленького віку
і я би хотів тут
таку сказати
цитату відомого американського філософа
і реформатора освіти Джона дюї який
сказав таку річ що якщо ми будемо
вчитися сьогодні так як вчили Вчора ми
вкрадемо майбутнє в наших дітей і саме
тому сьогодні дуже важлива наша
дискусійна панель дискусійна тематика і
в тому числі сьогодні дуже цікавий
класний день коли була презентація
університету президента
буквально годину тому і сьогодні якраз
ми будемо в тому числі і Теж про це
говорити і я хочу запросити зараз
передати слово
заступнику міністра освіти і науки
України Артур салевському
який зможе розповісти про найближчі
плани з цифровізації освіти і науки в
Україні пане Артур вам слово
дякую доброго дня колеги Доброго дня
шановні слідуючі так дійсно на початку
2020 року ми отримали такі виклик як
пандемія отримала тільки Україна весь
світ і дійсно не тільки в Україні були
проблеми а були проблеми у всьому світу
весь світ був не готовий до такої
пандемії яку ми отримали всі думали що
це максимум місяць S2 а там де вміє
затягнуло більше вже нічна 2 роки і тому
це питання також підштовхує нас для того
щоб ми виходили і застосовувалися більше
цифрових технологій
самий навчанні дійсно багато що вдалося
зробити нам з команди Міністерства
дійсно багато чого ми плануємо зробити і
упереджено наші проблеми які ми
визначили на цей за цей період ми
побудували стратегію розвитку зворот
трансформації освіти і науки сьогодні
також хочу її представити
вот напевно щоб зараз вивели на екран
слайд
будь ласка покажіть слайд
так ось ви бачите слайд Це перша
проблема яку ми з якого опікувались це
створення
освітнього середовища
так на сьогодні ми розуміли що не всі
вчителі не всі школи мали повне
забезпечення комп'ютерна техніка та
інтернетом разом з міністерством
трансформації ми почали працювати над
проведенням інтернету у кожного куточок
нашого держави на сьогодні день
Міністерство цього трансформації
виділено півмільярда гривень на те щоб в
кожній школі був в нас Інтернет
Також ми розуміли що і не всі вчителі
забезпечені комп'ютерна технікою і саме
в стратегію ми вклали те щоб забезпечити
комп'ютерну техніку наших вчителів в
наші школи на сьогоднішній день вже
виділено державний 980 млн на те щоб
кожен вчитель зміг отримати свій гаджет
і міг робити дистанційне навчання в домі
чи в школі також є чудовий проект який
також ми започаткувались громадською
організацією історія це прокачає школа
де долучається бізнес для того щоб
долучати прокачувати школу комп'ютерну
технікою Я думаю що сьогодні також ми
про це поговоримо
і Бізнес тоже допомагає ця синергія
бізнес бізнес і держава допомагає
рухатись фрезацію вперед
також другий друга ціль - це цифрові
компетенції ми розуміли що не всі
вчителі могли чимали можливість отримати
якісну цифрові контент і навчитись їм
користуватися ми розуміємо що це також є
велика проблема Так ми провели багато
перемовин з нашим партнерами це компанія
Google Microsoft зробили найбільші таке
навчання просто Уявіть собі 15 000
одночасно навчалося вчителів продукту
gcforducation від ну кооперації як
Google це підхопив Microsoft і також
зробили з ними навчання для вчителів
компетенція вам таку як впливає одразу
платформа Microsoft teams і там вже було
5 000 е-е вчителів які приймали навчання
Ми плануємо щоб це у нас було постійно і
долучаємо партнери і будемо самі
будувати різні платформи де будемо їх
навчати
і третій - Це сучасний зміст освіти ми
розуміємо що ми рухаємось вперед разом
зі світом і кожен наш вже дитина кажуть
народжується з телефоном в руках з
гаджетом в руках і не змінюючи сам
звісно освіти Ми будемо відставати а
саме такі чудові продукт як
Всеукраїнських школах онлайн про які
також сьогодні буде розказувати наші
колеги він зараз використовується просто
Уявіть собі 115 країнах світу
115 країн світу використовував наш
український продукт це всі майже
діаспори найбільші діаспори світу
використовують наш продукт це їх є
можливість навчатись по нашій
українській програмі А давайте візьмемо
з вами також і наші куповані тимчасово
окупована територія Де також у них немає
можливостей наразі навчатись на
українську програму і вже шість більше
ніж шість тисяч учнів прощаються по
нашій програмі онлайн
наступне - це трансформація послуг та в
процесі в сфері освіти тут ми вже багато
чого зробили зараз перегоном промований
у нас на ближчим часом має з'явитися
електронний електронна черга де ми
можемо відслідковувати і збирати
інформацію де потрібно де більше дітей
ми будемо від цього аналізувати і думати
де потрібно відкривати заклади освіти Де
найбільш горить себе на горяче це
питання Також ми вже запустили такий
продукт як електронний щоденники журнали
вже 500 шкіл користується цим продуктом
Це продукт розраховано більш на
неспроможні школи такі небагатші школи
на сельському місцевість і це не може
єдина можливість якщо в них немає коштів
використовувати безкоштовний продукт
електронний щоденники журналу - це
державний продукт
наступна ціль - це збір та обмін даними
освіти і науки ми зараз започаткували
розробляємо програмний інтерфейс для
того щоб всі комерційні продукти
сольоних цим межами могли
віддавати нам дані і ми могли їх
аналізувати про успішність учні і так
далі Як ви бачите вся стратегія
настільна те щоб зробити єдиний єдино
таку освітню екосистему яка допоможе у
нашим учням вчителям розвиватись почала
отримувати цифрові навички і втримати
цей контент які дійсно вони потребують
на сьогоднішній день вже багато що
зроблено вступівська школа онлайн на
електронний щоденники журнали зараз буде
ще в нас запускати з партнерами
позашкільна платформа де в нас будуть
зосереджені відображаються всі державні
а був майбутнім і не державі гуртки
і не тільки Міністерство освіти А це
міжвідомчий проект це буде імін спорт і
мінкульт де І також будуть їх гуртки
як батько Я хочу відправити дитину
кудись на позашкілля Я відкриваю просто
єдиний сайт і бачу все є всі всю
інформацію по позашкільному гурткам в
моєму місті наприклад я захочу щоб моя
дитина займалася музиками брала розділ
музика Я заходжу туди і бачу там вибирає
гра на гітарі Також ми хочемо в
майбутньому започаткувати єдиний
електронний
учнівський квиток який допоможе нам в
майбутньому ситуацію з соціальними
потребами наприклад що в Києві - це
безкоштовний проїзд в метро можливо бути
То в іншому місті саме в Рівному це
наприклад на тролейбусах тому дійсно ми
ви як ви бачите стратегічну ми рухаємося
потім проблемам які маємо на
сьогоднішній день і з кожним день ці
проблем стає все менше і держава стає
більш доступною освітою і більш мобільна
дякую Я хотів би продовжити що
цифровізація освітньої сфери це одна з
найважливіших речей зараз які є в міфи
1,5 пунктів Та я хотів би дати слово
якраз дмитру Дмитро
Розкажи що зараз відбувається з цифрові
світу які є новації і ми плавно дійдемо
до наступного проекту з освітні
платформи Дякую в міністерстві цифрової
трансформації Як ви знаєте є декілька
цілей взагалі стратегічних Міністерства
однією з цих цілей є розвиток цифрових
компетенцій цифрових навичок громадян
чому це взагалі важливо це розвиток
цифрових компетенції
кожного зараз в залі є в руках або в
кишені якийсь девайс і ви шукаєте
інформацію щось робите працює
теопрацьовуєте документи з телефона або
комп'ютера і так далі тобто ці
компетенції і вміння цим користуватися з
більшоюсь продуктивність вашої праці
що в свою чергу веде до збільшення
продуктивності праці загалом всередині в
державі тому Ми віримо що підвищуючи цей
рівень цифрових навичок цифрових
компетенцій в громадян будь-яких
професій віку і так далі буде
збільшуватися їх продуктивність праці
Для прикладу чи уявляєте ви собі
Наприклад фінансового директора або
просто фінансиста в вашому бізнесі який
наприклад не володіє там excellen або
комп'ютером або ще чимось тобто це
неможливо уявити зараз в будь-якій
професії
необхідні певні цифрові навички з чого ж
ми почали ми провели певне дослідження
більше року тому щодо цифрових навичок
громадян різних категорій різного віку в
різних регіонах для того щоб з'ясувати
взагалі Де ми знаходимося і для цього ми
взяли рамку цифрових компетенцій
Європейського Союзу яка називається
digicom
ця рамка каже про те що взагалі цифрові
компетенції діляться на 5 категорій
вмінь якими ми з вами в тому чи іншому
на тому чи іншому рівні володіємо перше
- це вміння працювати з даними пошук
інформації систематизація інформації і
так далі друге - це питання комунікації
або кооперації тобто вміння спільно
працювати
в інформаційному просторі і це вміння
може бути різним наприклад від того що
ви можете спільно спілкуватися в
месенджері або редагувати документ до
просунутих програм для колаборації
проектного менеджменту і так далі в
цьому розділі вони навіть виділяють
такий пункт як не тикет типу цифровий
етикет як спілкуватися ефективно з
людьми тому що ми звикли до певного
спілкування але ми бачимо Що наприклад в
коментарях в Фейсбуці спілкування не
таке воно інше і вона інше в месенджерах
вона ін пошті і так далі тобто вміння
спілкуватися ефективно в цифровому
просторі є зараз дуже важливим як вміння
комунікувати з людьми працювати в
команді воно набуває певних рис оцього
цифрової держави
Третє - це створення цифрового контенту
Тут також ми можемо йти від питання того
що я роблю пости в Фейсбуці і до
програмування тому що програмування - це
теж в свою роду створення цифрового
контенту вміння зафіксувати якісь накази
комп'ютеру на його мові четверте - це
безпека від захисту інформації і взагалі
базової якоїсь інформаційної гігієни і
до таких питань як захист довкілля тому
що я наприклад Ну і наші дослідження
вказують що дуже мало людей знають
наприклад відповіді на запитання як
правильно утилізувати ваш комп'ютер а це
питання стає все більш актуальним коли
держава закуповує на Як казав Артур
Миколайович на 980 млн грн ноут Буків
рано чи пізно ця техніка потребує
утилізації і люди мають знати як взагалі
з цим поводитись як утилізувати свій
гаджет який Вони змінюють Все частіше і
останнє це називається в рамці
компетенції proble solding то вирішення
проблем це вміння застосовувати інші
навички для того щоб
свої власні питання питання своєї
спеціалізації своєї професії вирішувати
для того щоб ці компетенції нарощувати
ми працюємо спільно з артурою
Миколайовичем особисто з міністерством
освіти загалом для того щоб
розвивати стратегію цифрової
трансформації інструменти для цього і
так далі а також ми створили проект дія
цифрова освіта це державний портал де ви
можете подивитися курси з цифрової
грамотності з безлічі різних
спеціальностей спільно з міжнародними
партнерами міжнародними організаціями ми
зараз створили вже більше 50 таких
курсів є спеціальні курси для вчителів є
курси для школярів Мені особисто дуже
сподобався курс з штучного інтелекту для
школярів
вважаються взагалі видатним результатом
який у нас вдався і вже більше ніж
півмільйона громадян пройшли Ці курси
отримали сертифікати Надія цифрова
освіта
крім цього от останнім часом ми
запустили декілька тестів з цифрової
грамотності як загальний тест так і для
вчителів і для держслужбовців для того
щоб люди могли оцінити свої навички в
цих блоках компетенції зрозуміти як
взагалі їм далі рухатися для того щоб в
першу чергу підвищити свою продукцію
продуктивність праці так не лише в
умовах пандемії а і загалом і ми
розвиваємо цю платформу і будь-який
ініціативи які стосуються
цифровізації освіти та науки
кожен день кожного місяця завдяки нашій
команді завдяки нашим партнерам от я ще
хотів подякувати всім хто нам допомагав
в цих проектах в рамках проекту дія
цифрова освіта Нам вдалося також
створити платформу всеукраїнська школа
онлайн де Міністерство освіти розміщує
контент для дистанційних курсів курсів
для змішаного навчання для школярів якою
вже скористалися більше 170 000 дітей та
вчителів але про це я так розумію що
далі ми будемо говорити тому Дякую вам
дякую Дмитре я буду зараз хотів якраз До
речі трошки продовжити
вашу тематику і запитати у наших
шановних учасників Скажіть будь ласка
хто підніміть руки хто хоть раз заходив
на платформу дія цифрова освіта
О тут всі всі вже знають а хто подивився
хоча б одну серію
достатньо нормально Так
Ми нещодавно проводили ще коли був такий
скажем тренд пік
соціальної мережі копхаус Ми там продали
теж різні такі
дискусії на освітню тематику серед в
першу чергу правда айтішників бо від
Мінських ви це робили і
так трапилось що якраз розповідали про
платформу про те що там дійсно є от
сказав Дмитро там неймовірні
круті пізнавальні відео про штучний
інтелект е-е про
кібербезпеку про різні тематики які дуже
дуже досить простими словами
розповідають про взагалі про створення
бізнесу про стартапи і це не тими
словами складними як для айтішників там
різним сленгом тут дуже простими словами
класно це так розказано що це Як це
велика рекомендація і зараз до цього
дійду обов'язково це треба дивитись усім
е-е нашим вашим батькам давати скажемо
поширювати цю інформацію тому що
виявилось після цього капхаусу до мене
звернулись одразу кілька моїх знайомих
які слухали наш нашу дискусію і запитала
з ким мені Лін будь ласка я про це не
чув не бачив Хоча вони знову ж таки десь
ми в друзях і бачать які з продукти він
цифри але ну якось воно пройшло не
побачили і вони скинули потім я отримав
фік е-е вони скинули з своїми батьками
вони придивились і один з там батько
мого друга розпочав зараз вивчати
штучний інтелект Йому 60 плюс років і
він якби взагалі там ніколи не був
летіти матиці і там скажем ну був в
нього є там схильність до скажімо
математики але він не займався
професійно тому що в нього інша сфера і
Після перегляду цього відео Він
зацікавився для того щоб дізнатись е-е
глибше про це все і інший момент який ми
також робили скажемо такі регіональні
поїздки і розповідали питали по регіонам
чи знають взагалі теж регіони люди про
цю платформу небагато ще знають і
після скажемо наших спілкуванні
пітчингів цієї платформи вже деякі
регіональні отг починають на своїх
соціальних мережах публікувати
інформацію про таку платформу І от ми
теж отримали великий е-е крутий фікбек
На їхній сторінках про те що це дуже
класна платформа і взагалі треба
поширювати це і тепер я хочу скажемо з
такою промовою підійти плавно до іншої
платформи яка не менш крута і і буде ще
більше Та розвиватись от це Анна Сидорук
яка розповість про всеукраїнську школу
онлайн Так це платформа яка в певній
мірі допомогла зараз там пройти певний
етап який був е-е з різними карантинами
локдаунами от Анна Прошу розповісти про
це
Дякую Дуже я розпочну з того що в нас в
команді є улюблена формула я попрошу
вивести її на екран вона звучить так що
діти це лише 20% від нашого населення
але це 100% нашого майбутнього
і саме з цією формулою Ми розпочинаємо
кожен проект над яким Починаємо
працювати і Всеукраїнська школа онлайн
вона не стала виключенням для того щоб
дослідити те як це працює в світі ми
вивчали досвід Естонії Канади США
Сінгапуру Британії Тож до роботи над
всеукраїнською школою онлайн на
світогляд підійшла з таким максимальним
ентузіазмом і з експертизою Якщо ж
говорити про ключові тренди які лежать в
основі бшо То це в першу чергу
мікронавчання і креативна подача
матеріалу я далі вам покажу ті якраз
креативні рішення завдяки яким нам
вдається цікаво подавати матеріал учням
це персоналізований підхід адже кожного
користувача всеукраїнської школи онлайн
є власний кабінет де він відслідковує
свій прогрес навчальний Кожен учень а
вчителі відповідно мають можливість
надавати зворотний зв'язок своїм учням і
таким чином обговорювати ділитися
досвідом і працювати під час організації
дистанційного чи змішаного навчання і
третій тренд - це інклюзивність для нас
Це питання було важливим що самого
початку Тож до співпраці ми запросили
таких найкращих експертів з інклюзії це
юнісеф команду уніро і кожен вчитель
всеукраїнської школи онлайн пройшов
навчання з інклюзивності освіти для того
щоб вже на етапі розробки навчальних
матеріалів врахувати всі особливості
сприйняття навчального контенту різними
дітьми
і над проектом працювало близько 80
вчителів ще близько 40 методистів і 60
експертів державних
все Це дало змогу створити
1800 якісних уроків для учнів з 5 по 11
клас які відповідають державній програмі
Це власне була ціль цифровізувати
шкільну програму і зробити їй цікавою
доступною і корисною для всіх учнів
нашої країни
якість цих уроків забезпечили 8 фільтрів
перевірки Це був такий досить непростий
виклик для нас і для всіх вчителів але
це допомогло нам зробити так що дійсно
уроки всеукраїнської школи онлайн вони
відповідають державному стандарту вони є
якісними сучасними і інтерактивними і ми
цим дуже пишаємося
Кожен урок всеукраїнської школи онлайн
складається з трьох основних компонентів
це невеличке відео тривалістю від 6 до
12 хвилин яке розкриває основну основу
теми І
скажемо так дітей змушує зануритися в
процес навчальний ще глибше досліджувати
цю тему далі йде коротенький тест на
закріплення знань і перевірку себе і
короткий конспект де є знову ж таки
основна вижимка якісь цікаві
кейси проекти над якими можуть працювати
спільно як учні так і вчителі
Якщо ж говорити про креативну подачу
матеріалу то зараз це просто Must тому
що сучасних дітей неможливо втримати
просто якимись навчальними визначеннями
чи
термінологією у нас на всеукраїнській
школі онлайн ви наприклад можете
зустріти Instagram одноклітинних або
познайомитися з Інстаграмом Юлія Цезаря
чи дізнатися про те як відбувалося та чи
інша битва в 3D
візуалізації з максимальними деталями
для того щоб дітям було цікаво і вони
занурювалися в навчальний процес одним з
таких фаворитів серед уроків є урок
орфографії Хто б міг подумати але
цінність його в тому що вчитель
побудував урок таким чином що разом з
персонажем казки Маленький принц вони
подорожують різними планетами вивчаючи
правила написання різних слів
Якщо говорити про кількість користувачів
то дійсно активних користувачів такі які
зареєстровані постійно навчаються станом
на зараз в нас є понад 170 тисяч і це
користувачі зі 115 країн світу До речі
Після України що цікаво лідери це
Німеччина Нідерланди США Канада тобто
країни в яких рівень якості освіти
досить високий і ми так розуміємо що там
дуже активна українська громада діаспора
і їх діти навчаються там за українською
програмою
126 тисяч учнів вже є активними
користувачами платформи кожен П'ятий
український вчитель-предметник є
користувачем всеукраїнської школи онлайн
Ми цим дуже пишаємося це результат лише
кількох місяців роботи платформи і ми
щиро віримо в те що користувачів буде
ставати все більше і більше Адже для
вчителів це жодним чином не є заміна їх
роботи це додатковий інструмент який
допоможе зробити їх роботу більш цікавою
якісною і комфортною і близько 8 тисяч
слухачів
також на платформі є така опція як
кабінет вчителя де це по суті
віртуальний клас куди вчитель запрошує
своїх учнів діти реєструються і вони
разом вже працюють над вивченням певної
теми це допомагає не просто дитині
самостійно вивчати матеріал а ще й
отримувати зворотний зв'язок від вчителя
працювати в групах за своїми
однокласниками А це дуже важливий ось це
відчуття коннекту з вчителем з
друзями своїми шкільними тому що якби
там не говорили а якраз організація
дистанційного навчання напряму залежить
від вчителів і ті вчителі Яким це класно
вдалося по суті від них залежить весь
навчальний процес далі то вже на
всеукраїнській школі онлайн Існує дві
тисячі ось таких віртуальних класів де
навчаються діти разом зі своїми
вчителями
і буквально нещодавно ми з командою мін
цифри і Міністерство освіти презентували
мобільні додатки всеукраїнської школи
онлайн для операційних систем iOS і
Android ви можете за цими qr-кодами вже
завантажити і за тестувати
всю якість це дозволяє навчатися дітям
ще більш комфортно і зручно адже 70%
користувачів всеукраїнської школи онлайн
заходять на платформу саме зі смартфонів
тому власне Ми з командою І вирішили
зробити навчання ще більш зручним тобто
матеріали завантажуються більш швидко
більш зручно плюс є якісь нагадування
для учнів то вони точно не пропустять
коли з'являться якісь нові уроки на
платформі
От і перед тим як я попрошу
продемонструвати коротенький ролик про
мобільні доданки Я хочу поділитися з
вами ще однією цифрою якою Наша команда
дуже пишається це те що 6 тисяч
користувачів всеукраїнської школи онлайн
це діти з тимчасово окупованих територій
які просто зараз
навчаються там за українською програмою
українською мовою Таким чином отримують
доступ до якісної освіти через
цифровізацію
А тепер можна і ролик подивитися прошу
включити будь ласка
[музика]
там було написано зроблено з любов'ю
і Я би дуже хотіла ще скориставшись цією
можливістю подякувати всім партнерам як
державним партнерам так і донорам фонді
сайт фонд Відродження також мобільним
оператором які зробили безкоштовний
трафік для користувачів платформи Це
означає що кожна дитина яка має смартфон
і сім-карту навіть з нулем на рахунку
може навчатися безкоштовно на
всеукраїнській школі онлайн І за це моїм
дуже вдячні Дякую за увагу а на дуже
круто взагалі люблю до кінця коли щось
цікаве дізнаєшся про те що проникнення є
навіть не тільки в Україні а поза межами
України так і ми ще думаємо це побачимо
що я в процесі наступних років
проникнення збільшиться і в Канаді
Сполучених Штатах
це дуже круто я ще в мене є питання з
приводу API до платформи продукту але це
трошки пізніше ми зараз будемо рухатись
парламенту щоби всі ноти слово зараз
дати слово Вадиму крандію директор
українського інституту розвитку освіти
повинні почути про партнерство так про
які кейс громадського державного
партнерства ви можете розказати і які є
цікаві інструменти для цього
дякую по-перше пані тому що я нібито
отримав пас і маю Продовжити далі дійсно
партнерство - це є перевага цього
проекту і не тільки цього як показала
практика українці можуть об'єднуватися і
творити гарні речі а саме у партнерстві
і роботі таких речей бо можуть
з'являється нові цінності і нові
розуміння якості Я прошу дати картинку
щоб просто розуміли про обсяг тих
інституцій громадських організацій які
були за презентацію зараз
дякую
наразі це досить тривалий процес я маю
сказати якби це робилось виключно силами
держави це був би процес який би
розтягнувся на роки а так було задіяно
дуже багато інституцій і починаючи від
центральних органів виконавчої влади тут
є гарний приклад співпраці двох
центральних органів це Міністерство
освіти науки та Міністерства оборони
інформації а також громадські
організації
освіторія як об'єднавчого майданчику на
якому об'єднали сіль для досягнення
певної мети це долучення системних
донорів які підтримали цей проект це
бізнес який дав можливість реалізувати
певний ресурс для того щоб
конституційний і головне - це наші
неперевершені вчителі тому що саме
вчителі привнесли сюди бо ми говорити
відчуття реальності відчуття новизни це
вчителі які є переможцями Всеукраїнських
конкурсів професійної майстерності це
молоді вчителі які мають достатню
енергію щоб поділитися цією енергією з
усі знаходиться навколо них і ми бачимо
що дійсно будемо говорити таких проектах
народжується нові сенси в таких проектах
з'являється нова якість я дякую всім хто
долучився до цього тому що це дійсно
продукт який я ще раз говорю від моменту
прийняття рішення і до моменту появи
перших уроків був створений лише за два
місяці ти продукт якому на сьогодні
всього півроку Це продукт який зараз є
лише базовий і функціонал якого
розвивається далі Я думаю що продовження
буде продовження буде в тому що наразі
Ми плануємо знову ж таки спільними
зусиллями дати можливість створювати і
поповнювати цей матеріал самим
педагогічного працівниками Я думаю що в
наступній півроку у нас має з'явитися
функціонал конструктору уроків що більш
урізноманітні можливості його але мабуть
найбільшою цінністю цього продукту є в
розумінні його якості - це доступність
Та інклюзивність оце є головні
інноваційні моменти що момент викликів
пандемії стали
драйвером розвитку цього має сказати що
ми маємо дуже гарно партнера ми маємо
українське представництво юнісеф в
Україні який підтримало нас У цьому
сенсі яке також виступило об'єднавчий
майданчиком для наших фахівців А в нас є
достатньо фахових людей в сенсі
інклюзивності Наразі по рівню
інклюзивності даного продукту він є
неперевершений і на цьому Ми не
зупиняємося тому що ще деякі моменти
зокрема звукопис буде Додано цих уроків
щоб мали можливість їх переглядати ті
діти які мають певні обмеження Я думаю
що ми будемо мати можливість читати те
що там знаходиться з канрі драми У більш
кращому форматі кращою якості має
сказати про те що взагалі поява таких
продуктів сприяє тому що розвивається
Наш вчитель наразі в грудні Минулого
року прийнято новое професійний стандарт
де серед інших складових визначено
цифрову компетентність нашого вчителя і
тому можна обійти питання переведення
формату
підвищення кваліфікації нашого чистеля у
цифровий формат має сказати що знову ж
таки за підтримки юнісеф
спільної із громадської організацією
соціальна синергія наразі готується
досить крутий продукт це тренажер мкф
для інклюзивної освіти взагалі мкф - це
міжнародна касифікація функціонування
обмежені життєдіяльності та здоров'я е-е
працюючи з цим
інструментом вчитель отримає розуміння
бо ми що він повинен зробити для
конкретної дитини для того щоб навчання
для неї стало більш інклюзивним і більш
доступним наразі соціальна синергія
спільно з українським інститутом
розвитку освіти базуючись на цьому
тренажері розробили програму підвищення
кваліфікації і я сподіваюсь що найближчі
дні Ця програма почне діяти суть полягає
в тому що вчитель не тільки не буде
нових компетентств в галузі інклюзії
інклюзивного навчання А також після
проходження відповідно навчання на цій
же платформі зможе у режимі повної
анонімності
деперсоналізації даних змоделювати
профіль свого учня і зрозуміти що
потрібно зробити в сенсі інклюзивності
для його покращення Ну і якщо ми
заговорили за підвищення кваліфікації
мабуть дуже важливим є спільноти
спільноти які творять оці нові якості
які творять нові сенси спільнота яка
утворилась навколо вшо це є вже досить
потужна спільнота яка довела те що
здатна творити нове Я маю також
презентувати що завтра має
почати працювати і бути відкритою для
широкого загалу
платформа підтримки професійного
розвитку педагогічних працівників
яка наразі реалізується едкемпом
громадської організації за підтримки
фонду Відродження пенсійним партнерами
чого є
Український інститут розвитку освіти
державна служба якості освітній
омбудсмен і інститут освітньої аналітики
тож запрошую всіх доєднатися до теї
презентації платформи 1 червня тобто
завтра і я думаю що у подібних проектах
і спільних діях є наше майбутнє дякую
Дуже дякую На жаль ми маємо таку річ як
регламент і я думаю що вона дуже цікава
дискусія і ще би не вистачало нам
queenday питання відповідей від
території Я думаю ми Потім можемо
поспілкуватися з кожним підходьте до
кожного фахівців експертів які сьогодні
є зараз я хочу сказати слово Сергію
клибошино у заступнику голови комітету
Верховної Ради України з питань освіти і
науки
Сергію Івана чуєте
Я сподіваюсь мене те що
я да ну було б дивно якби ми розмовляли
про цифровізацію освіти і дистанційку і
не було людини яка в дистанційному
форматі ввімкнулася
я так коротенько саме я спробую для того
щоб зрозуміти над якими проблемами ми
працюємо далі І де ми знаходимося
скажемо так ну по-перше чи все в нас
добре з цивілізацією освіти не треба
питати експертів поїти до будь-якої
школи або поспілкуйтеся з батьками і
зрозуміємо Що нам ще працювати і
працювати але просто для порівняння щоб
було зрозуміло де Ми знаходились ще
півтора-два роки тому 0 цифрового
контенту від держави Я шкільну освіту в
першу чергу кажу реально от ми коли
починали працювати рік тому і робили
першою терацію школи онлайн Ми
зіткнулися з тим щоб контенту взагалі
немає
фактично повний відсутність сервісів від
держави згадаємо сумну історію про
Національну освітню електро платформу та
ті Кошти які на неї витрачені і чи хоча
б там п'ять людей по Україні і її бачили
Ну і хаос на ринку всі бігли за
електронними під електронними журналами
електронними щоденниками гравці майже ну
фактично там шукаючи якийсь там
заробіток в цьому де ми знаходимось
зараз я думаю що багато вже експертів
про це казали я не буду повторюватись і
про ту роботу яку виконує Міністерство
цифрової трансформації звичайно
Міністерство освіти і науки і в першу
чергу ви про школу онлайн ми тут
згадували про платформу перепідготовки Я
про те чи задоволені ми до кінця і чи
розуміємо Куди нам рухатися далі
Звичайно що не до кінця поїдьте ще раз
повторюсь до будь-якої школи і спитайте
А як у вас наприклад під час пандемії
відбувався освітній процес десь це було
зразковим простору десь Ну прямо от ну
ідеально Я не знаю Можна там розповідати
з будь-якої високої трибуни але дуже
багато шкіл то це було як я шахи за
листуванням тільки навчання за
листуванням причому в прямому сенсі
вчитель-предметних телефонував класному
керівнику казав які параграфи там
прочитати дітям а потім ніяк це
наконтролювати фактично і це Ну Повірте
це не просто випадковість там чи окремий
випадок це дуже-дуже багато шкіл тобто в
нас поки що колосальна нерівномірність і
тут бо я торкнувся до речі і
проблема яка стоїть перед школою онлайн
це більше проблема не самою школи онлайн
а наша завдання ми на минулому тижні
мали виїзне засідання комітету нашого в
артеці пуща-водиці і там було десь 25
дітей з ну з
самоврядування там артеківської і так
далі Тобто діти зі всією державою і ми
просто спитали хто користувався хоча б
раз школою онлайн з 25 там чи 30 дітей
дві дитини підняли руку це каже про те
що нам ще працювати і працювати щодо
впровадження ну зрозуміло 125 чи 127
учнів декілька мільйонів у нас 500 тисяч
тільки вчителів державі якщо повертатися
до вчителеї і до тієї субвеції яку
держава виділила в цьому році Ярд 980
мільйонів на придбання засобів ноутбуків
для вчителів то можна просто порахувати
і розуміємо це що мільярд на ну в
середньому 15-20 тисяч на ноутбук це
50-60 тисяч вчителів знову повторюсь в
державі в нас півмільйона вчителів Ми би
такими темпами можемо 10 років або
поставляти а потім замінювати бо вони
будуть вже застарілі або ми маємо
суттєво працювати з місцевими бюджетами
я нагадаю що засновниками школи
працювати і є ще один аспект - це
багатодітні родини де особливо в
сільській місцевості де нема такого
великих коштів родини один ноутбук а
дітей 3-4 та навіть дві дитини як їм
ділити цей ноутбук для того щоб
вести навчальний процес це теж питання і
тут нам треба шукати нові механізми в
тому числі і співпраці повторююсь з
місцевим самоврядуванням
я б нагадав би ще про такі аспекти Як
нема класної відповіді принаймні в мене
що робити із соціального компонентою
якщо ми кажемо про дистанційку
пошкодилося ж не тільки квадратні
рівняння школи ще й спілкування робота в
командах і так далі І тут ну на 100%
замінити онлайн не зможе
як нагадав би про те що величезне
завдання перед нами стоїть щодо
цифровізації початкової освіти бо теж
школа онлайн це 5-11 класи і пам'ятаю
наші дискусії там рік тому і півроку
тому А як і що робити класно для
перших-четвертих класів бо там треба із
батьками теж більше працювати Що там і
як зробити для того щоб той формат який
зараз в школі онлайн Ну він не буде от
абсолютно Ок для перших-четвертих класів
і
Звісно що
цифровізація освіти Ну не дорівнює
тільки дистанційній освіті Звісно що
цифровізація це є про сервіси і тут я
просто тут гаряче Вітаю те що робить Він
це міцифера Бо як я полюбляю казати
воїни воюють на джинси снапжають і коли
ми нарешті надали можливість там
проводити інтернет до школи тим хто має
проводити Інтернет а не самим школам щоб
вчителям то ми маємо Ну дійсно різницю Я
згадую декілька років тому була
залишки освітньої субвенції під мільярд
десь міносвід розподілила по місцях для
того щоб інтернет проводити і шале
не менше половини здається не було
засвоєно оскільки ну мають робити
інтернет ті хто вміють робити інтернет
вчити мають ті хто вчать і вот Ну ми
мали підсумки зараз от ну це нормально
історія і звичайно це створення тих
сервісів про які казати Дмитро і Артур
про Ну як і не тільки про дистанційку А
які в тому числі і про електронні
щоденники але якби тут зауважив що
передміно світу стоїть велика завдання
переосмислення ну скажемо так різних
нормативних документів бо ми можемо
скільки завгодно вводити безкоштовні
коштовні і так далі електронні щоденники
ажурнали якщо ми не змінимо і надамо
можливість в школі тільки в онлайні
працювати з документами нічого не
зміниться бо зараз коли приходиш до
школи із питаєш вони кажуть А навіщо нам
дві роботи робити Навіщо нам і паперовий
журнал заповнювати і електронний журнал
це не витрачання якихось коштів Це
просто здоровий підхід ну Але знову ж
повторюсь той факт що ми зараз через два
роки фактично через півтора від тієї
стартової точки з якою я почав говоримо
про вже існуючу базу контенту про ті
Шалені кроки які зроблені щодо
інфраструктури і Ми не боїмося говорити
про цю проблематику це вже ну супер ну
це реально супер Я вважаю що в
цифровізації освіти за от останній рік і
там півтора в нас дійсно шалений такий
от стрибок відбувся хоча поки що це
маленький стрибочок для всього і людства
хоча для однієї освіти однієї
європейської держави це величезний
стрибок Дякую пане Сергію Дуже дякую
і зараз хочу перейти до наступного
нашого фахівця експерта і я сьогодні
зранку тому саме Твітері що будуть буде
дискусійна панель з з експертами з
іменами і мені дві людини не написали що
будь ласка Запитай про tiktok Я думаю що
зараз я це людина не потребує
додаткового особливого представлення
Михайло Михайлович Поплавський Розкажіть
будь ласка про ваші інновації про тік
ток Що зараз ви робите Як Ви взагалі
залишаєте і зацікавлюєте студентів Дякую
Ну я хочу сказати що це сьогодні
історичний день 31 травня щоб підписаний
Указ Президента Володимир Зеленським про
створення університету майбутнього це
дає можливість всім вусам підтягнутися
тому що ідея геніальна Але треба ще її
реалізувати А для цього що потрібно
перше ідея є потрібно
як це робити І третє взяти і зробити Я
думаю відкриття буде десь влітку так
слідуючий року Так планується чи в цьому
році
відкриття університету жовтня 23-го року
Ну ви запитали мене про Я хочу вам
сказати що ми увійшли в соціальні мережі
у 18-му році факультет дистанційного
навчання у нас наприклад 90% всіх
соціальних мережах викладачі професори
Ну наприклад
декан веде повністю прямі прямі діалоги
я маю до соціально Ну наприклад у ДК не
мають по 400-500 підпищиків в Інстаграмі
Я маю 2 млн 300 підписників в Інстаграмі
ті хтоки десь 265 потому що ті хто це
підліткова група це Молодіжна група і ми
працюємо з ними з ними Як то кажуть
обличчя в обличчя саме головне що по
понеділкам 19 до 20-ти я з ними в
прямому ефірі Спілкуюся А що потрібно
сьогодні для молоді що або молодь тобі
довіряє Або тобі не довіряє і сьогодні
Ти переконуєш що ми тут краще ми їх
приїжджаємо ми фактично на творчість
спеціальності уже завершили набір тільки
ЗНО ЗНО у нас менше цікавить вона
цікавить самородки таланти тому що вони
в селах в районах містечка а поставимо
200 якщо самородок поставимо 200
потворчому іспиту і заберемо навіть якщо
не витягує на бюджет ми його візьмем за
рахунок університету ми можемо собі
дозволити ми десь 20 берем талантих
дітей безкоштовно а я вважаю що е тікток
можна по-різному сприймати але ті хто б
це тоже е-е молодь там сидить якщо ви
подивитеся мій тіток там написав все
українські тренди що я українізую
тік-ток
Подивіться Всеукраїнське Все повинно
потому що треба підтримувати українське
проводити українські навіть ми створили
сало і українські вареники які пішли по
всьому світу стала набрала 5 млн 300 за
два місяці а українські вареники
наберуть 10 млн це теж культурна
дипломатія в дії це теж один з елементів
е піару і я хочу сказати що на
сьогоднішній день Я зараз я готуюся
зробити український борщ бо тому що
росіяни там щось з нами соряться судами
займаються щоб був український борьба це
ж Україна то есть це теж ідеологія можна
по-різному сприймати Ну я такий є тако
маєте і на сьогоднішній день Хочу
сказати уже на творчість спеціальності в
нас 8-10 чоловік на місці попереднє
зарахування пройшло і якщо говорити по
великому рахунку то
сьогодні декан які не в соціальних
мережах за в кафедри які не в соціальних
мережах які реально не спілкуються він
не цікавий ми його просимо до побачення
на творчу роботу
повинні бути молоді креативні так нас
дикани до 40 років заступники декана до
30 років повинен бути енергія повинен
бути бажання Ну і мотивація у нас
зарплата дозволяють дозволяють і я хочу
сказати що я скажу якщо
університет любий не в соціальних
мережах Подивіться сайти які погані в
деяких університетах це все це вони
сходять з дороги історії сьогодні треба
атакувати життя Сьогодні Треба рухатися
вперед то есть як казали класики
включати музей ще велике булками Якщо ми
будемо йти вперед значить буде нормально
А якщо ми будемо сидіти ну під лежачий
камінь то ніяк не тече спасибо
Я ще скажу Що дивіться тут у нас
сьогодні присутній на на інший
паралельній дискусії один
співзасновників найпопулярнішої
українського додатку який займається
технологією діффейків і ця компанія
планує в цьому році запустити соціальну
мережу і вона має потенціал стати
напевно ну єдиною і найкрутішої
соціальної мережі в світі з Арт і
мистецтва тому що у вас же інститут
культури мистецтв от я пропоную взагалі
можливо після дискусії вас познайомити
та і вже наперед пропрацювати напевно
теж якусь присутність в цій соціальній
мережі Я хочу користуючись нагодою всіх
запросити краще один раз подивиться в
університет культури і мистецтв чим тут
кілька кілька хвилин почути я всіх
Запрошую в любий час з 15:00 до 18:00
дякую
так
І зараз хочу передати слово танелу
кересту керівнику is School з Естонії
пане лечу на нас
Я вас чую Дякую за те що мене запрошено
хотів сказати дві слові з естонського
берега так би мовити
я репрезентую компанію що називається
екозначає Господи
це школа і ми говоримо за керування
школою Сьогодні я хотів би вам дати
огляд цієї системи як ми почали її
розробляти а потім і вживати 20 років
тому може зважити і вже маємо деякі
висліди є чим поділитися і похвалитися і
деякі цікаві речі що у нас виробили
тобою пандемії
будуть питання То прошу звертатися радо
відповім
що це таке система керування школою
система інклюзивна тепер модно казати
включно е-е тут є
комунікація тут є
під'єднання і дуже багато
для керування школи керування шкільним
роком шкільним тижнем тощо
Отже коли ми починали цю працю це був
початок
нашого тисячоліття десь 20 років
може кінець 90-х років навіть
коли два проєкти два головних провідних
тогочасних в Естонії один був
Tiger Lite це фундація
стрибок щоб
стрибати з комп'ютерами до школи так би
мовити
і другим
важлива річ це був почин Урядовий
щоб розглядати
основи
освіти для тих дорослих що мали
опанувати комп'ютери Інтернет щоб
Інтернет прийшов до книги збірник
бібліотек до всяке громадське місце
це фундація
що
мала саме то це проведення комп'ютера до
школи
актуально коли прийшов комп'ютер завітав
до школи то з'ясувалося по школах ми
маємо вже комп'ютер А що ж тепер робити
з тим комп'ютером
Отож наступна в нас було
додати якогось
програмного забезпечення бути
комп'ютерів щоб школа могла працювати на
щодень
потім школа сама сказала
А ну ж
Зробили цей електронний
щоденник чи електронний щоденник нашої
шкільного життя щоб керувати школою нащо
день
тоді декілька шкіл зібралось і зробили
спільний проєкт тоді це
був такий
фонд що надав Лав
фінансування для нових печінь проект
найперша версія
2001 року практично вже 20 років ми
працюємо Отже я можу сказати
що є одна чи дві школи що не вживають
жодних електронних щоденників у себе
таких залишилося Як то кажуть відсталих
Отже
99% 99 сотих
того вживають і це вже головних слави
тому що полегшує життя бачите
ще деякі речі
стосовно до самого проєкту
ми з'ясували
видатний ми маємо здобутки від того часу
ви можете чули що Естонія
має дуже високий
позиції
електронні послуги електронний щоденник
допомагали сягнути цієї високості тому
що
вчителі
змушені були вдатися до комп'ютера ми
знаємо що починати і завжди важко
Перший млинець левкий а далі вже легко
стає
вже вчителі насахаються від комп'ютерів
як 20 років тому
зробили початок добре початок це
пів діла як то кажуть
Ось так з'явилася Наша перша система
[музика]
керування школи та встановленого каналу
між
школою родиною і тоді починаємо
запроваджувати систему керування
навчальним процесом це І настав що вже
історія в Естонії маємо три чи чотири
різних систем і альтернатива що є
міжнародні системи але якщо ви зробили
канал То тепер там каналам уже легше має
пускати потрібні потолки І
за такий канал править наша система між
домівкою і школою
і ще одна важлива риса коли ми робили
цей продукт
Ми думали що треба триматися той засади
що тільки раз
та Гаразд таке було наша гасло тільки
раз питання
до системи щоб не повторювати Вони мають
бути адекватні можна поділитися із
учнями
батьками усі
вчителі це бачать
директори завідувача навчальної системи
частина Вибачте І все всі це роблять
вчасно не треба докладати якось
додаткової праці не треба писати звітів
нескінченних справність вся інформація
на підставі такого підходу навчила нас
того що вчителі справді
[музика]
виконання всяких
адміністративних завдань бо вони
заощаджують 45 хвилин десь на день тому
що їм не треба більше якихось додаткових
звітів писати Комусь
не потрібно через те що все робиться
автоматично Електрон це робить сама
система це може прозвучати банально але
45 хвилин людського життя можна його
віддати дітям
і
цієї системи на 30% на 5 років зменшив
якщо взяти
20 років то на
90-95 відсотків на скоротили
І відсутність гучність тому що батьки
все бачать тепер
хто є в кого нема в школі і тому та
система раннього сповіщення якщо дитина
починає
бути схильною до прогуляництва разом і
помічаємо все розв'язуємо проблему
швидко і тоді проблеми не погіршується
не за давніше
батьки
також беруть участь у процесі учіння і
навчання на 90% все
ведиме для батьків вони сприяють домашнє
завдання у виконанні готінки
є обмеження щодо часу у нас слово ви вже
також маємо такі жорсткі рамки маємо
завершувати я хочу сказати на останок
про те що
цифровізація світу неминуча і
онлайн-технології вже невід'ємна
складова нашого життя і лиш провадивши
їх на всіх рівнях ми зможемо змінити
нашу країну І взагалі полегшити життя
усіх наших громадян і нас українців Дуже
дякую всім
дякуємо
дякуємо усім учасникам цієї дискусії цих
презентацій Дякуємо Запрошуємо далі до
спілкування із пресу із колегами які
присутні тут на українському форумі
Україна 30 зовсім скоро ми повернемося
до основної зали у нас буде третя сесія
Цього дня форуму Україна 30 освіта і
наука і ми поговоримо про Суспільство
знань та популяризацію науки причому не
тільки із загальними баченнями у нас
будуть
представлені гравці на цьому ринку Як то
кажуть і ректори університетів і
представники Національної академії наук
України із сучасних хакатонів із
розробками та пошуками талантів про все
це на форумі України 30 за кілька хвилин
[музика]
что наконец-то и государства и бизнес
находится на одной стране и готовы для
совместных операций для того что
производить лучший Кадры и более
востребовые Кадры Мы обсудили в ряд
проблем и задать Что можно сделать для
того чтоб быстрых результатов Да вот Нам
нужно очень бизнес образование добавить
техническому потому что применять все
технические знания а-а в бизнесе
пока что для выпускников это недоступно
да то есть это этим заниматься
национально бизнес сейчас обучает этих
людей после университетов
переквалификацию не могли применять свое
знания бизнесен и вот одна из программ
которые мы занимаемся образователь это
популяризация системы образования среди
женщин на самом деле я читаю таким нашим
огромным кадром резервом очень мало
деффчонок До сих пор идет работать
или учиться э-э там на Steam профессии
Ну это того где очень сильно Украина
может э-э вырастить потому что их много
Ну как выселилось на самом деле
це експозона з українського форуму
Україна 30 поруч із основною залою де
відбуваються презентації і сесії
обговорення виступів також волелюдно І в
наших Як то кажуть куларах форуму де до
кожної теми представлені свої експозиції
ці три дні наука і освіта і відомий для
киян і думаю тих хто час від часу
відвідує столицю незважаючи на карантин
зараз все ж таки Музей Науки малої
Академії Наук на ВДНХ він сьогодні
приїхав до нас розкажіть більше про цю
локацію у рамка форуму в рамках форуму
Ми зібрали найцікавіші експонати які
показують різні сфери з фізики з хімії з
біології людини де ви зможете відчути
доторкнутися до науки зрозуміти що таке
популяризація науки через прості
аналогові рішення або якісь позиції де
ви просто фізично побачити як
відбувається цей процес іде дасте
питання Чому це так працює і отримаєте
на нього А давайте пройдемося навіть
дещо покажемо
нашим глядачам бо що ви можете
перевірити відчуття часу ваше Ми
наприклад як саме починаємо
починаючи йти різні лампочки світитися
потім перестають і треба нажати тоді
коли воно буде на стоп вгадати коли воно
буде саме там відповідно коли ви А чому
Це відчуття саме часу тут більше реакція
на Ні не можна
Ну ви не бачите де вона світиться коли
воно починає от давайте запустимо от я
бачу бачу зараз перестає світитися і ви
маєте
і натиснути я мав тоді коли вона коли ви
здогадаєтеся по відчуттю що саме тут
буде ця лампочка а там якийсь алгоритм
Чи це Працює таким чином щоб перевірити
як ви відчуваєте свій час тобто
наприклад ви коли рахуєте до 10 кожна
людина рахує по-іншому да відповідно ви
слідкуєте за цим напрямком це механізм
просто вмикає перестає світити ці
лампочки ви його вмикаєте на момент
чесно я заплутався Давайте до іншого
експонату а оце все що у нас подвійний
спуск це для фізики так більше давай ви
Візьміть давайте якось мікрофон Так так
чи Давайте я потримаю Давайте давайте Ви
тримайте мікрофон а я так і от я
наприклад що спускаю да я ставлю тут А
ви там Скажіть будь ласка який Як ви
думаєте який шарики в перший спуститься
донизу А ви могли би мене не от не
ганьбити перед глядачами
я щось не так відповіла насправді от він
не знаєш фізику ще жарту це буде
раз два три Ну у мене трішки я раніше до
представника Але
одночасно суть так насправді ці два
шарики спустяться одночасно незважаючи
на те що вони були в різних частинах
цього треку це Зрозуміло Тому що тут
такий кути тут буде більше скажімо
розгін Так нам здається що тут вище буде
швидше але ця форма це є форма циклоїда
яка була зустріти давно інший кут нахилу
відповідно там буде інше розгонна
Скажімо так сила а що це за
дзеркало для мене знаєте як людини
театрально Здається це більш
електромобіль для
гримування актриси
ви поставите свою голову всередину то і
будете рухати цими дзеркалами То ви
вийдете на те що ваше обличчя буде
нескінченне тобто
відображення відображення відображення
відображення Так що ми Зараз поставимо
ми не під певним кутом ми не Побачимо В
нескінченне зображення А якщо ми зробимо
інший кут і дитина може експериментувати
це не є Стала історія дитина може
відчути як це відбувається і далі
поставити сюди будь-який предмет
наприклад там свій мобільний телефон і
рухати безпосередньо і дивитися під яким
кутом буде який буде виникати ефект а
Давайте спробуємо так розумію навички
водночас і геометрії і це теж частково
якісь речі які стосуються безпосередньо
що таке оптика як свідок з фізики так як
відображається що таке дзеркало як воно
працює Давайте спробуємо через вас
пропустити струм
почалося Давайте до почалося тепер струм
на комусь уже випробовували бо
випробовували на
людях вже випробовували а на людях не
випробовували випробовували зараз на
пацюках і тепер вирішили наведучому так
одну руку ставте на наприклад на
алюміній
одну руку на алюміній на алюміній іншу
наприклад на місці Ну ви сильно не
грайтесь ваше записує я це розумію ці
наукові інтриги і з втратою ведучого ну
така комбінація да комбінація пропускає
через вас дуже мало а струму але все
одно пропускає тому що комбінація
алюмінію і я зрозумів що не дуже сильно
так давайте алюміній і мідь бачу добре
більше зараз ви пропускаєте 50
ампер тому що людина є
електропровідна і через вас вивів як
провідник струму через цей проект Ну я ж
не ковтаю німітні алюміній зараз це
тільки я повертаюся долонями Це мається
так трохи ваш організм він пропускає
струм насправді кожен момент іноді
бувало таке що ви там торкались якось
предмет і у вас Било Ну да тому що це ні
до того що моя пропускна зрозумів струм
пройшов Але чому саме відрізняються
прийомні оці від е-е залежить від
матеріалу від їх струмопровідності
мокра це ж буде Ну більше тут не такий
рівень струму відповідно це не загрожує
вам абсолютно
це буде більше е-е площа і експериментів
учасників речі
своєю провідністю в чому це залежить
наприклад я можу спробувати зробити
Давайте ви давайте
у вас так да
Ви маєте доста давайте Тепер я так само
зроблю
так цинк і мідь
у мене менше чому чому я воду п'ються що
від чого це може залишити це залежить
там від біології людини від особливостей
вашого організму це вже
в дану експонат це не демонструє
відповідно він демонструє саме ефект але
суть в тому що це ж зацікавити наукою
популяризати науку що просто ставляться
більше запитань від дітей Так вам в
школі просто кажуть людина проводить
струм
так так всі знають а це показує що
дійсно ви є Ви замкнули зараз електричну
мережу але посуда є допитливі такі як я
вредні Як то кажуть да вони почнуть А
чому так А чому так тому у нас в
просторі працюють унікальні люди це 20
інтерпретаторів в музеї науки не
працюють гіди які тебе водять за ручкою
або вчителі це працюють інтерпретатори
це молоді активні люди які пояснюють
всім зацікавленим школярам дорослим якщо
виникає Якесь питання навпаки задають ці
питання тобто і мотивують до того щоб
людина а саме запитувала саме це їх
основне завдання інтерпретувати науку і
відкривати її для широкого кола осіб у
вас тут дуже насправді цікаво і цікаво
Візьміть Тоді будь ласка мікрофон ми
можемо залишити на потім людям Давайте
ми ще з вами ще ж тут три дні форуму
якщо можна показати А це що це за
порчені Русі ви спочатку покажи що я не
зламав нічого це дуже простий механізм
Ми всі знаємо якщо є поршні в
автомобілях візьміться за ручку повзунка
да е-е як його переміщувати що привести
в рух колесо Ну ось наприклад да да
Якщо завдання для вас важке ну це от
натяк на мене да Для вас це дуже складне
питання да це про мене спробуйте
спочатку трохи повернути колесо в плані
так все нормально працює ну це може
маленькі діти да Якщо це дитина там 3-4
років її може бути складно
крутити і відповідно пропонується
зробити інші дії дуже важливо розуміти
що основна цільова аудито unintelligible
музеїв це діти 6-12 років які тому
експонати вони розраховані на на зріст
маленької дитини і тут так ну це так так
само колесо поїзда те що ми ну старі так
так Паровози цим
просто я зворотнього так от роблю О
бачите так працюєте енергію і колесо
відповідно
рух якщо ви бачите що коли ви рухаєте
туди ви рухається в зворотній бік Це
дуже чудово Ми ще мусимо не раз
повернутися наші в експозони Хоча вони
уявляєте наскільки у нас цікаві є
експонати і Враховуючи те що зараз поки
в Україні триває тривають карантинні
обмеження як і по всьому світу із певною
їхньою рингуванням і ступеню обмежень Ми
не можемо усіх усіх вас запросити
учасники форуму усе це бачать але ви
зможете бачити завдяки нашим трансляциям
на сайті Ukraine 30.com або на нашому
каналі в Ютубі ще зустрінемося дякую
інвестиції в навчання - це інвестиції в
людський капітал у
1992 році професор економіки черкаського
університету Гаррі бекер отримав
Нобелівську премію за це дослідження він
зробив розрахунки і довів що інвестиції
в людський капітал дають більшу віддачу
адже більш освічені люди швидше
ухвалюють рішення краще працюють в
умовах стресу менше хворіють бо
займаються профілактикою і рідше
змінюють місце роботи
знання - це скарб а вміння вчитись ключ
до нього українська освіта змінюється
[музика]
вона стає гнучкішою і сучаснішою
цифровою і безбар'єрною наука все більше
цікавить молодь розробки і винаходи
перетворюються на стартапи а держава
підтримує і мотивує
всеукраїнський форум Україна 30 освіта і
наука
це всеукраїнський форум Україна 30
освіта і наука
Суспільство знань і популяризація науки
Що це таке і яким чином це здійснюється
розмова і тими якраз із представниками
і е-е самої Академії наук і вищих
навчальних закладів і
людей які представляють інновації
мудрує цю дискусію генеральний директор
директорату науки і інновації
Міністерства освіти і науки України Юлія
Безвершенко дякую доброго дня колеги
Шановні учасники форуму та ті хто
дивиться нас онлайн Рада вас вітати на
цій сесії хочу представити колеги які
сьогодні зі мною будуть розкривати тему
суспільства знань та популяризації науки
пан Володимир бугров ректор Київського
національного університету імені Тараса
Шевченка
пан Євген кудрявець заступник директора
малої Академії Наук України з
міжнародних відносин пані Олена
Компанієць переможниця
номінацій-техноличих хакатону НАСА Space
челендж молодший Наукова співробітниці
головною астрономічної обсерваторії нан
україни Катерина Терлецька доктор фізмат
наук старша Наукова співробітниця
інституту проблем автоматичних машин і
систем Національної академії наук
України і пан степурін директор
видавництва саміт-книга також з нами
онлайн пан Міко мілікоски який є
сіофінського наукового центру Доброго
дня Отже колеги сьогодні ми будемо
говорити про Суспільство знань що таке
Суспільство знань це суспільство де
створення поширення та використання
знань є ключовим елементом його розвитку
його розбудови забезпечення добробуту
громадян та розвитку економіки ми будемо
сьогодні говорити на форумі в цій сесії
саме про поширення знань в третій день
цього форуму будемо говорити про
створення знань та їх використання на
практиці але всі ці елементи є важливими
для того щоб досягнути кінцевого бачення
цієї концепції до неї є два підходи
історичний - це коли розглядають
Суспільство знань як не уникне і
наступний етап розвитку суспільства
постіндустріальне
суспільство коли на зміну використання
праці людей збиральництва те що дає
земля у вигляді
агропродуктів чи у вигляді корисних
копалин на зміну цьому приходять знання
продукти з високою доданою вартістю Які
створюють нові технології змінюють
кардинально світ в цій концепції
суспільства знань розглядають якщось не
уникне те до чого ми прийдемо
автоматично в іншому підході який є
Поліссі підходом або підходом політик це
те майбутнє яке ми маємо сконструювати
це один із варіантів тоді коли
забезпечується відповідне намір держав
політична підтримка фінансові інвестиції
в освіту та науку розвиток інновацій з
тим щоби у можливо це Україна сьогодні
на порозі свого 30-річчя Незалежності ще
чітко неартикулювала як вона бачить свою
силу свою конкурентну спроможність на
світовому ринку змагань різних держав
але я певно що той інтелектуальний
потенціал який ми маємо потужні наукові
школи тобто люди яких ми маємо в цій
країні є тим що дає нам підставу вважати
що Україна може і має мати амбіцію
розбудувати Суспільство знань тут якщо
ви це декларує Європейський союз якщо це
декларують розвинені країни світу то
Україна не може стояти острів Я певно що
сьогодні разом з колегами ми розкриємо
частину цієї концепції дізнаємося Що
сьогодні робиться в Україні для
розбудови суспільства знань і
продовжуємо це робити В наступні дні
Отже Я запрошую до слова пана Володимира
бугрова і сподіваюсь почути від вас як
наука яка подекуди може здаватися
далекою від життя конкретної людини
допомагає нам в житті повсякденному І як
це побачити Дуже дякую пані Юля
насамперед хотів би сказати що
сьогодні вкрай важливим
викликом для українського суспільства є
поновлення наукового світогляду адже ми
з вами є свідками коли цілі телевізійні
канали присвячені
гороскопам і гадалками віщунам ми бачимо
на сьогоднішній день масу випадків коли
люди скаржаться на те що повелися як як
прийнято говорити на якій з обіцянки на
щось
несерйозне І це не лише в повсякденному
житті це навіть в певній продуктивні
виробничої діяльності чи щось таке і ось
тому для нас як
університету-дослідницького Бо насправді
я за фахом є викладач філософії але в
нас в університеті є два підрозділи які
готують біологів два які готують Хіміків
три які готують фізики чотири які
готують фахівців з it ми маємо
географічні геологічний факультет дуже
багато різноманітних якраз
природничо-наукових та що взагалі
відноситься до стан для нас Важливо щоб
ті хто приходить до нас це вступники
були якісно підготовлені Отже ми
екстраполюємо науковий світогляд на
школу скажімо ми маємо одну школу у
складі самого нашого університету Це
український фізико-математичний ліцей
який має
чудові результати вивчення фізики хімії
математики інформаційних технологій але
цього мало тому ми сьогодні йдемо до
шкіл і через малу Академію науки через
олімпіади конкурси через відкриті
вектори формуючи не лише абітурієнта але
формуючи середовище без якісного
середовища
сформувати фахівця А на нашу думку
стан це є національна безпека держави ми
бачимо сьогодні як розведення країни
світу
вимивають в жаргонному виразі але наші
міста І тому ми повинні
що забирають люди виїжджають через те що
там кращий рівень життя То ми повинні
наново наново готувати для себе для
інших університетів тут не важливо до
нашого ми для себе але ми працюємо і для
інших має бути середовище друга теза на
яку я би хотів звернути увагу насправді
так нас на сьогоднішній день надзвичайно
мало те що називається науково-популярна
література
науково-популярні медіа коли я був
школярем це були журнали там техніка
молодежи ну російською мовою звісно там
юни технік металіст-конструктор і багато
чого іншого і все це формувало
відповідне середовище на сьогоднішній
день ми маємо
кейс абсолютно практично абсолютно е-е
відсутності таких видань от єдиної
української журнал який жавлює мені
здається До сих пір це в Україні знань
Які редакція видавала ну по суті так на
волонтерських засадах Але що ми тоді
хочемо як зворотний високе середовище
якщо
фактично немає ні медіа ні телебачення
в Широкому сенсі Які би пропагували
науковий образ світу через те ми маємо
масу прикладів з анти вакцинації ними
поглядами з гомеопатією з
віщунством і таке інше яке впливає знову
ж таки на національну безпеку тому що
давайте свідомо скажемо що на сьогодні
позиція провакцинування це є національна
безпека і саме тому третя та за яку на
яку я би хотів звернути увагу це якраз
от
освіта і наука в медійному просторі на
сьогоднішній день ми маємо фактично
0 кейсів успішної людини науковця
вченого освітяна щезу освітянами зараз
так-сяк А ну за останні 10 років Я
жодного випадку щоб
було просування в медіа успішного
науковця фізика математика
Я не бачу і це є проблема тому що
всі наші медіа заточені під адвоката
прокурора бандита так у багатьох
серіалах як приклади успішної людини і
по суті немає от я наводив на
прес-конференції приклад ви як фізик
знаєте про відкриття одерона так в
Україні рівно два видання написали про
це газета Київський університет і газета
Голос України де я в інтерв'ю сказав що
що таке але ну коли в нас запитували
інколи про відкриття світового рівня так
ось вам приклад відкриття
публікаційна увага нуль професор Ігор
комаров інститут високих технологій
людина з премію гумбольта
Людина яка робить те про що ви сказали
фото чутливі ліки так те що в принципі є
проривом в хіміотерапії лікування
ракових захворювань
уваги з боку медіа майже нуль якби ми на
рівні університету не проводили ось таку
інформаційну політику то взагалі тому Я
закликаю всіх хто присутні тут і хто
дивиться нас повернутися обличчям до
школи
повернутися обличчям до
науково-популярного середовища
повернутися обличчям до популяризації
учених як успішних людей інакше через це
на прес-конференції сказали повторюю Цю
тезу інакше Через 5 років нам не буде
чого ось тут збиратися дякую дякую пане
Володимире отже
[оплески]
Отже ми вже зачепили питання формування
середовища насправді популяризація науки
і несення світла знання в маси Це в тому
числі для того щоб люди потім формували
правильний вибір при виборі школи
виборюванні університету вибори
траєкторію свого життя і маленькі вибори
нашого щоденного життя І власне похід
науковців до людей наука для суспільства
це дуже непросте питання тому що наука -
це справа не багатьох людей які за ці
сотні років просунулись дуже далеко в
розумінні світу і це потрібно просто
красиво цікаво пояснити тим людям які
можливо від науки далекі незалежно від
того діти це чи дорослі Я запрошую до
слова пана Євгена який я думаю може
розказати нам про успішний якийсь того
як власне наблизити науку до людей з тим
щоби вони потім користувалися нею в
житті і поважали її будь ласка Дякую Юля
Вітаю колеги я хотів би якщо можна
розпочати
з невеличкого відео Ну багато і так
будемо говорити для такого загального
настрою будь ласка
якщо можна увімкнути
там ще звук є це теж наука
у нас на одному з основних пострілів
написано фізика музика У нас навіть
приходили артисти виконавці які роблять
цю фотографію тому що вони себе не
асоціюють з наукою але співають і такі
це дуже така потужна
потужний момент
замість музики тоді буду я озвучувати
третього жовтня 2020 року відкрився в
Україні Музей Науки малої академії наук
це сталось на 65 років пізніше ніж перші
двері відкрив центр науки у Сполучених
Штатах А це був перший центр науки у
Детройті і після цього вони почали
ширитися по всьому світу головна мета
центрів науки ми його називаємо Музей
Науки це відкрити для молоді науку та
безпосередньо дати можливість
зацікавитися тими чи іншими науковими
явищами які є навколо нас я свідомо
використовую відкрити та зацікавити аніж
просто навіть популяризувати тому що
головне завдання не просто показати
науку головне завдання щоб кожен хто
відвідує а в даному випадку це і діти і
дорослі міг міг зрозуміти як це
відбувається зрозуміти що йому
подобається і Іноді я дуже часто
повторюю коли кажуть що так ну не всім
же подобається наука але іноді навіть
зрозуміти що тобі не подобається тому що
потім коли ти робиш пев Я думаю вибір Ти
вже десь там згадуєш а мені це не
подобалось ну тобто є вже певна певне
розуміння а в Києві що таке Музей Науки
в Києві це 120 інтерактивних експонатів
створених в сім експозиційних зон
спільно з світовими центрами та музеями
науки ми робили це в колаборації з
досвідченими організаціями по всьому
світу саме У нас ви можете зробити
неможливе ви можете поїздити на
велосипеді на квадратних колесах яких
всього чотири в світі ви можете єдину
дозволеному місці спробувати розбити
скло і це абсолютно легально І у вас за
це ніхто не буде наказувати А ви можете
розібрати людину на частини іноді це теж
дуже потрібно для заспокоєння ви можете
зробити ще безліч чудових речей які
відкриють вам чудеса науки ви будете
думати що це чудеса але потім ви в
процесі поясне розумієте що це насправді
не просто чудо
головне правило в музеї заборонено не
торкатися Тому це
перша відмінна історія від просто
нам звичних відвідувань музеїв дуже
часто ми чуємо запитання і я хотів би
сьогодні як момент діалогу цього про це
поговорити чим можна головним зрозуміти
відмінність між
розважальним холем в торговому центрі де
залишають дітей на певний проміжок часу
батьки і відвідуванням центру наук або
музею науки це вже питання неймінгу як
на мене головна відмінність - це
відсутність фейків це справжність що я
маю на увазі Уявіть собі у вас є
мобільний телефон або будь-яка кнопка
якою ви там розважальному центрі дитина
або ви натискаєте
за результатом цього відбувається щось
там б'ється якийсь предмет злітає м'ячик
починає грати у вас з мобільний додаток
щось відбувається у вас формується хибне
причина наслідкове зв'язок що натискання
цієї екрану або кнопки призвело до цього
результату який ви побачили на екрані
або в цьому залі насправді ж цією
кнопкою ви лише запустили велику
кількість механізмів які Створювалися
великою кількістю людей великої
кількості років які дали можливість
відбутися цій події в результаті Музей
Науки і це ми називаємо фейком тобто
натискання не призводить до цієї дії в
музеї науки побудовано все таким чином
що ми показуємо не натискання кнопки ми
показуємо безпосередньо оцей процес який
відбувається
Таким чином дитина має змогу а дитини
дорослий будь-який хто відвідує на музей
він може зрозуміти що це не просто чудо
А це чудо стало завдяки певному
кількості дій які відбуваються на
безпосередньо у тебе перед очима наше
завдання дати можливість дитині побачити
ці процеси відчути їх зрозуміти
зацікавитися тому що
ми ставимо за мету виховання Таким чином
покоління молодих українців які здатні
до створення творців тому що якщо ти не
знаєш що відбувається всередині Ти не
розбирав не дивився не розумієш ну а що
таке цей там оптика що це таке Ну там ну
мабуть окуляри у мене там кричали там
оптика оптика Ні це ну це не просто це є
певні певні процеси які призводять до
розуміння цих речей і далі для того щоб
ти був творцем У тебе має бути певні
характеристики ти маєш бути сміливим
ризиковим відповідальним Але для того
щоб все стало працювати ти маєш задати
має у дитини у людини особистості
виникнути два простих запитання чому І
як це працює і за результатом ми робимо
все для того щоб у дитини виникло це
питання і на первісному рівні воно могли
бути мати відповідь Це питання у
просторі музею а далі якщо навіть 5%
дітей зацікавляться чому Як це працює і
після цього записується в певні наукові
напрямки в наших лабораторій Малій
Академії Наук або почнуть створювати
свій стартап або ще щось це абсолютно
різні треки які дають можливість почати
розвиватися в Україні Коли буде питання
Чому і як саме ми для цього працюємо і
робимо три дуже важливих позицій Ми
тримаємо баланс між фаном і Education
між розвагою і освітою це така формула
знаєте як поділити де є там вже науковий
певний центр центр науки а де ще
розважальний центр в торговому центрі це
оцей баланс між розвагами і освіти якщо
баланссувається в бік освіти але при
цьому Ми маємо зберегти тому що ми фан
тому що ми конкуруємо на ринку якщо
говорити такими сентенціями конкуруємо
за увагу дитини в мобільному телефоні в
комп'ютерних певних соціальних мережах в
якихось розважальних комплексах які для
них є більш звичними і так далі ми
конкуруємо Відповідно ми маємо зберегти
цей фан але дати не безпосередньо певну
освітню складову саме тому тут така гра
того що аналогові рішення вони більш
мають бути файнові і зрозуміємо що у
музеях науки по світу відмовляються від
екранів тому що екрани і так повсюди
крани так повсюди діти вже навчились
натискати на сенсо екрани ми максимально
намагаємося від цього відійти і
третя складова - це
боротьба зі стереотипом ми
маємо таку комбінацію двох стереотипів
музей - це нудно у людей так і наука це
нудно одразу А ми Музей Науки ну тобто
ми ну вдвічі нудно ну але
це боротьба зі стереотипом працює Дуже
просто Ми кажемо
вітайте до музею під дві години в музеї
Ви зрозумієте що і музей може бути не
нудно і наука може бути нудно і це
абсолютно нормально і ми маємо кейси
коли музей виконує перші першу головну
її мету певну формування напрямку для
дитини що вона хоче що подобається і яка
у ній у неї улюблена наука знаєте Музей
Науки це такий аналоговий варіант тесту
на Фейсбуці моя улюблена наука Тобто ти
проходиш і в результаті у тебе
висвічується напис моя улюблена наука
оптика і у нас є кейси коли шестирічна
дитина підходить до інтерпретатора це
такі унікальні люди в просторі які
допомагають зрозуміти науку краще і каже
знаєте я от походив тут я для себе шість
років зрозумів що я хочу бути лікарем
тому що саме зона людини вразила дитину
найбільше або вражень і батьки які
виходять із музею кажуть Я не міг
подумати що моїй дитині подобається
матеріальнознавство я навіть не знав що
таке буває і дитина у захваті виходить з
цьої будівлі і розуміє що їй хотілось би
дізнатись більше про матеріали як вони
працюють як вони живуть саме тому Ми
запрошуємо всіх до музею Музею долучений
до світової спільноти ми вже
впроваджуємо з червня а-а рішення
абонементи на безлімітний відвідування
музею який вперше в Україні дає вам
маючи цей
абонемент Ви маєте доступ до всіх
світових центрів науки безкоштовно тобто
будучи частиною цієї всесвітньої мережі
ми розуміємо що ця глобалізація певний
доступ до Світового ресурсу його
створити і максимально дати тому
вважаємо що це має стати таким кроком до
зацікавлення це лише
тільки перший рівень Тому далі вже
відповідно працюють всі інші рівні
освіти чекаємо вас у музеї науки Дуже
дякую дякую пане Євгене те про що ви
казали це від популяризації до залучення
причому це залучення в залежності від
етапу життя людини може бути різним від
фармаційного коли дитина вирішує чим її
цікаво займатися через те що вона
спробувала це руками і побачила не в
нудному форматі А змогла задати це чому
і отримати відповідь і закінчуючи
залученням уже дорослих людей які
можливо після цього поставлять собі
питання А що я маючи свій бізнес маючи
свою професію можу зробити для того щоб
поширювати знання щоб допомагати
популяризації науки тому що те про що
казав пан Володимир і те про що казав
пан Євген це речі які складно продаються
в світі якій наповнений багатьма
візуальними простими стимулами які
відразу дають виділення дофаміну і людям
добре не треба думати не треба робити
маленьке навіть інтелектуальне зусилля
будь ласка Олена продовжують я думаю про
залучення в науку на різних етапах життя
починаючи від дитячого віку Так дякую
Юлія тож усім Доброго дня Вибачте в мене
голос трішки може бути захрипший тому що
попередні два дні в нас був
всеукраїнський фестиваль з робототехніки
і один день Ми були залучені як
організатори А вчора дві команди
приймали участь безпосередньо тож свою
розповідь Я б хотіла почати з
кожної історії колись коли я була ще
маленькою дитиною я дуже сильно
полюбляла дивитися на Зоряне небо і мою
цікавість палку підтримував тато більше
того тато неймовірно багато розповідав
мені про космос і весь мій життєвий шлях
від мого дитинства і аж допоки я не
пішла навчатися до університету саме
тато завжди підтримував дискусії на
космічні теми А за рахунок цього моя
цікавість яка з'явилася колись давно в
дитинстві до космосу адже Зоряне небо
таке неймовірне і там стільки зірок І
хто знає скільки їх всього у нашому
всесвіті а через те що тато підтримував
цю цікавість вона нікуди не зникла і за
рахунок цього я в дитинстві як мріяла
стати Ну я тоді ще не знала що була така
професія яка астрофізик Але я точно
знала що я хочу вивчати космос
а і за рахунок цієї підтримки Я виросла
і дійсно пішла навчатися в університет і
вивчилася на астрофізика тож перший дуже
важливий пункт в формуванні наукового
світогляду в дитини і її цікавість - це
середовище в якому вона зростає Тобто це
батьки і сім'я Якщо батьки цікавляться
різними темами це не обов'язково космос
Так але в будь-якому разі вони
цікавляться читають і хочуть дитині
розповісти щось цікаве дитина буде це
все запам'ятовувати підхоплювати і
розвиватися разом зі своїми батьками тож
якщо ми хочемо щоб в дитини з дитинства
формувався науковий світогляд ми маємо
розуміти що самі батьки мають бути в
першу чергу в цьому зацікавленні крім
середовище в якому зростає дитина також
неймовірно велику роль відіграють
викладачі Мені пощастило тому що всі мої
викладачі завжди можна підтримували і
саме вони запросили мене писати свого
часу роботу в мані
я прийшла в роботу в мені почала писати
в дев'ятому класі і так аж до 11-го
класу і Звісно це було пов'язано Із
сонцем ман Це був той Стимул для мене
який мотивував мене читати більше книг
спілкуватися з науковцями подорожувати
Україною для того щоб більше розібратися
в тій темі яку я обрала тому дійсно якщо
ви бачите що ваша дитина цікавиться
наукою Ідіть до малої Академії наук і
нехай вона вже зі шкільного віку починає
робити Свій маленький науковий шлях
зрозуміло що до того щоб стати науковим
ще треба буде неймовірно багато вчитися
і зусиль прикладати але це теж ті перші
кроки які допомагають підтримувати
цікавість В дитини а крім цього Також я
вже почала говорити про викладачів в
школі саме викладачі це є ті
факели Я б сказала які запалюють у
дитини Вогник
і якщо викладач може цікаво розповісти
дитині цей Вогник ніколи не згасає Це я
вам говорю як викладач тому що я вже
більше чотирьох років викладаю в там
школі інвентор дітям різні дисципліни
зокрема цей робототехнікою фізику І коли
вони шестирічні приходять до нас і
говорять Вау мій робот поїхав
починається все з робототехніки
наприклад просто сконструювання потім
плавно заняття переростають в дискусію
про те що Ну вам часу не вистачає то
злітайте до чорної діри там час йде
повільніше виспитесь прилетите тут вже
2048 рік і вам вже нікуди поспішати не
треба буде тому що локально час біля
чорної діри протікає повільніше тобто
Здавалося б що це звичайні заняття де
немає ніякої астрономії але коли
викладач знає якісь цікаві факти і може
розповісти дитині щось цікавеньке вони
це підхоплюють тому що всі діти від
природи дослідники просто в різних темах
комусь подобаються експерименти хтось
хоче більше щось цікавенького почитати
про космос До речі космос зараз майже
безпровід безпрограшний варіант в плані
популяризації науки і
залучення дітей їхньої мотивації до
розвитку взагалі і вивчення Як
іт-технологій так і природничих
дисциплін тому що всі ми мріємо
подорожувати до космосу і можна починати
тут з прикладів що якщо ви вийдете і
подивитися на Зоряне небо то неозброєним
оком ви можете побачити там ну не більше
ніж 6000 зірок але це дуже мала доля від
загальної кількості тих зір які є в
нашій галактиці а тепер на хвилиночку
уявіть біля кожної зірки майже біля
кожної зірки є мінімум одна планета десь
вона вже сформована десь вона тільки
починає формуватися
і ми собі навіть уявити не можемо
наскільки багато різних світів може бути
І що там взагалі може існувати і для
того щоб дати відповідь на ці питання
зрозуміло що нам необхідно продовжувати
вивчати наш всесвіт зрозуміло що зараз
дослідження космосу вони якщо це
фундаментальні дослідження не дадуть
якогось нам Прикладного результату
сьогодні чи завтра тому що ми в село
обмеження наших технологій Ну не можемо
полетіти до іншої галактики але ми
отримуємо знання про Всесвіт і Як
говорив колись Арістотель Я буду там
вивчати просто для того щоб знати так от
отримуючи знання про Всесвіт
розширюється наше розуміння того як все
влаштовано і тому саме цим
фундаментальні науки і зокрема
астрономії є корисними А коли ми
розуміємо як все влаштовано ми можемо
пояснювати дітям Чому саме Так це такий
замкнений цикл Чим більше ми знаємо тим
цікавіше ми можемо щось дитині А на моїй
Я наприклад от як викладач кожного разу
на заняттях намагаюся дітям розповісти
якийсь новий цікавий факт Наприклад чи
знали ви що нещодавно марсохід персевера
за допомогою пристрою mox який розміром
насправді приблизно як тостер а зміг
синтезувати кисень тобто отримати кисень
з атмосфери Марсу напряму чому це такий
важливий результат тому що всі ми мріємо
про те що колись буде колонія на Марсі
не через те що хтось хоче втекти з землі
а через те що Просто хочеться
подорожувати сонячною системою ну
принаймні це є рушій прогресу для
мрійників а діти мрійники і коли ви їм
починаєте розповідати що людство стало
на крок ближче до того щоб полетіти в
космос і пожити трішечки на Марсі тому
що науковці вигадали як з атмосфери
кисню отримати вони сидять такі то може
я коли виросту зможу полетіти в космос
Ну мабуть треба вчити
фізику або математику ну і з власного
прикладу я наприклад до 10 класу не
розуміла математики для мене вона
виглядала як набір якихось незрозумілих
ієрогліфів дивишся там ABC всі букви
якась із них відомо якась невідома і це
я хочу вам сказати і всім хто нас слухає
для
мотивації ніколи не здаватися математика
насправді це мова будь-якої науки тому
що математика дозволяє нам описати красу
нашого світу і те що вам спочатку може
здаватися складним насправді просто
означає що треба прикласти трішечки
більше зусиль тож зараз Я трішки
узагальню для формування в дитини
наукового світогляду важливо роль
відіграє середовище це батьки це раз
друга невід'ємна частина - це викладачі
і це дуже проблемна тема зараз для
України тому що викладачів з
фундаментальних дисциплін зокрема з
природничих наук з фізики кожного року
стає все менше а для того щоб дитина
цікавилася наукою і в неї формувався
науковий світогляд Вона має навчатися
викладача який викладача який буде
розповідати так що у самого вогники в
очах горіти будуть і пояснювати фізику
от Як ви говорили на прикладі досвідів
не формулами і складними словами тому що
можна звісно говорити веселка А можна
говорити дисперсія але дитина може і не
зрозуміти що це таке треба спочатку
показати досвід розповісти чому так а
тільки після цього переходити до формул
тому що з фізикою в більшості дітей
виникає стрес через те що їм спочатку
дають купу формули складної термінології
але взагалі не говорять що ці формули
описують і це та проблема яка потребує
вирішення і її вирішувати треба етапі
популяризації викладача і престижності
професії викладача так щоб наші
викладачі були вмотивовані дітям цікаво
розповідати а також в якийсь момент у
нас зруйнувався міст комунікації між
науковцями і суспільством тому що Хто як
не науковці можуть популяризувати науку
і Вчитися цікаво розповідати про науку
не тільки дорослим але й дітям і це те
що ми зараз молоді науковці намагаємося
подолати Ми дуже хочемо відновити оцей
міст комунікації суспільством і вивести
його на новий рівень щоб діти могли так
як наприклад нас це комунікує з дітьми
коли діти записують відеоповідомлення і
запитують в науковців щось так само що і
наші діти розуміли що в Україні є багато
науковців які відкриті до комунікації і
якісь з радістю будуть розповідати щось
цікавеньке і давати відповіді їм на їхні
запитання
так тож батьки вчителі і науковці і
звісно розумієте в 10-11 класі коли
дитина розуміє що від мрії треба
переходити до вибору реальної професії
завжди постає фінансове питання І допоки
наші науковці отримують таку заробітну
плату якої не вистачає реально навіть на
оренду однокімнатної квартири в Києві
діти не будуть йти в науку навіть якщо
їм вона дуже цікава тому
підтримка науковців і Наукової молоді в
цілому в Україні Це теж те питання яке
наразі є Поки що не до кінця вирішеним і
якщо ми хочемо щоб наші діти росли і
могли реалізовувати свої мрії
досліджувати світ і розвивати в цілому і
Україну і людську цивілізацію в
майбутньому ми маємо вирішувати і
питання яке пов'язано з фінансуванням і
науки і освіти в Україні Дякую Олена
дякую
власне щойно Ми отримали таке коротке
відповідь на питання не питання проблеми
сформульовано паном Володимиром та і
паном Євгеном про успішного науковця в
Україні якого можна було би показати
власне український науковець - це такий
амбівалентний продукт української
30-річної незалежності який з фінансової
точки зору в більшості випадків є зовсім
неуспішним і в цьому сенсі рольовою
моделлю не може стати порівняно
наприклад з фахівцем зайці Разом з тим
як ви бачили тільки що наприклад по
олені це людина в якої в українській
науковець на прикладі Олени це людина в
якої світяться очі яка коли починає
розповідати про математику не болісно
зітхає згадуючи всі дитячі травми яка
каже що Математика - це та мова якою ми
можемо зрозуміти природу її красу можемо
закодувати і передати якісь іншій людині
яка має зовсім інший культурний код І
власне Я думаю Катерина Терлецька зараз
продовжить як науковець який здійснює
популяризацію науки розвивати цей диск
курс про те А що все-таки українське
науковці роблять для того щоб наблизити
Україну до суспільства знань навіть в
своїх непростих умов
прозруйновані мо
Так в мене лише є презентація Я думаю що
це буде трохи навіть повтор того що ми
Про що ми говорили тільки що Але в мене
це тепер з картинками з цифрами із
висловлюваннями тож мене звати Катерина
Терлецька я доктор фізико-математичних
наук я науковець і наука це моє життя і
мені дуже приємно і велика честь для
мене сьогодні
представляти
національну академію наук України адже у
мене дві афіляції одна з яких це
Національна академія наук а інша - це
Мала академія наук України Про яку ми
сьогодні тут дуже багато говоримо і це є
освіта і в принципі це є вже перша
відповідь щодо комунікації між
науковцями і суспільством ми бачимо що
це питання Воно є досить складним Ось
така картинка про те що дійсно і казали
що мости зруйновані і їх треба
налагоджувати але але не тільки між
науковцями і суспільством в нас вже є
проблема між поколіннями коли вчителі не
можуть донести щось дітям тому що в них
є різні цінності і в принципі в чому ж
причина Причина в тому що світ дуже
швидко змінюється і ми як вже говоримо
сьогодні опинилися в суспільстві знань і
Суспільство знань в має головну цінність
- Це знання і так само їх поширення які
ж є шляхи поширення в цьому суспільстві
окрім інтернету окрім не знаю
мультимедійних якихось засобів знання в
цьому суспільстві активно поширюється за
допомогою телебачення за допомогою
журналів з допомогою радіо Тобто всі ЗМІ
залучені до популяризації науки до
поширення знань і ще один шлях поширення
знань - це освіта Так але коли залучайте
науковців до освіти то науковці завжди
виникає питання взагалі а для кого я
буду створювати цінність а-а і це дуже
філософське питання і на яке ми маємо
відповісти взагалі в освіті а Ми
створюємо цю цінність для батьків да які
хочуть бачити щасливою свою дитину чи
для держави яка хоче мати
прогрес або це для дитини або дитина -
це є наш клієнт і відповідь імовірна
така що так дійсно це є дитина але
дитина не Та яка є сьогодні
наш клієнт - це дитина через кілька
десятків років це громадянин України -
це людина яка критично мислить це людина
яка є відповідальною І що ж можуть
запропонувати науковці для того щоб ми
мали таку людину через кілька десятків
років а це є
відповідь на це лежить в рамках того що
ми зараз даємо нашим дітям це є купа
фактів це якісь знання набір знань бо ми
зараз як науковці розуміємо що знання
узагальнюються Виникають нові науки Да і
купа знань не є відповіддю на те що ми
можемо дати як науковці Сьогодні дітям А
зараз дуже потужний світовий тренд який
називається Наукова освіта ось ви бачите
sciencedecation А
це тренд і це саме про відповідальних
громадян
єдине що коли ми говоримо про освіту
наукову освіту в Україні Ми не розуміємо
що таке Наукова освіта це для нас як
морська свинка і не морська і не свинка
і не наука і не освіта Бо коли ми
говоримо про науковця науковці кажуть
діти не можуть робити науку да І це
правда А коли ми звертаємося з науковою
освітою до освітян то вони кажуть
комод Це нам зайвий клопіт що ви нам це
якась нова ваша булька ні насправді Це
дійсно навчання дитини науковому методом
це є можливість якщо ви Спитаєте
наприклад у науковця що таке науковий
метод він вам скаже Оце те чим я
займаюсь це запитання це є формулювання
певних гіпотез передбачень перевірка цих
гіпоте це експерименти вони можуть
справджуватися можуть Ні це
призводить дитину до того що вона
починає критично вмислити вона стає
відповідальною тобто ось цей інструмент
Саме те що можуть дати науковці ті
майбутній людині яка буде керувати яка
буде
в нашій країні через кілька десятків
років
але коли ми успішно це робимо ми успішно
науковці дають цей інструмент наприклад
вчителям Малій Академії Наук ми
розробляємо
методики наукової освіти Ми зацікавлюємо
дітей Ми даємо їм цей інструмент але
коли ти питаєш дітей а Чи хочете ви
стати науковцями це ж круто так круто
Але науковцями а не хоче стати жодний з
них Але чому Тому що мабуть діти знають
ситуацію яка зараз відбувається в
національній академії науки про те що ми
сьогодні тут говорили ми не просто ще
раз цифри Да ми бачимо що кількість
молодих вчених а в національній Академії
наук за останні 10 років зменшились
вдвічі це дані З останньої сесії
загальних зборів яка була проведена
кілька днів тому і якщо ми подивимось на
фінансування Національної академії науки
в одиницях середньої зарплати взагалі в
Україні ми бачимо просто якісь
смертельні піки Пробачте да тобто
фінансування зменшується якщо наприклад
ми з підставимо ось фінансуванням освіти
Міністерство освіти тоїзниця
фінансування Національної академії наук
приблизно 25 раз менше тобто на науку в
нас не виділяються кошти ми бачимо що
середня зарплата в національній академії
внук не дотягують до 10 тисяч тому куди
ми запропонуємо от тому майбутньому
українцю йти І творити науку А на жаль
це мріє да І якщо дитина закохана в
науку якщо вона хоче займатись на скоріш
за все вона просто поїде з країни і ми
її не втримаємо тобто зараз цими
заходами ми є стимулюємо їх цікавість
розвиваємо але тут в нас нема середовища
де вона зможе реалізувати свої мрії Ну
але в принципі науковці працюють і нам
своє робить а і що науковців
Національної академії наук я можу
сказати що ця популяризація вона на
нашім ентузіазмі здебільшого а це просто
маленька частина тих платформ тих
площадок тих видавництв на яких науковці
нану себе презентують частина з них от
Це мій проект дійсно наука який ми
чотири роки тому створили ми проводимо
лекції в будинку вчених в онлайні Зараз
ми отримали невеличке фінансування з
громадського бюджету А так само інших то
роблять на ентузіазмі хто робить це за
якісь мінімальні гроші і дійсно є
небайдужі громадяни України які теж яких
теж є мріє розбудувати сильну державу і
отримати того майбутнього українця
майбутнього українського науковця і вони
дають трибуну для українських науковців
та роблять їм промоцію тому А друзі я
хочу сказати що ми робимо все можливо
від нас але
майбутнє української науки той майбутній
український науковець так само залежить
і від вашої волі від тих хто сидить в
цьому залі та тих хто приймає рішення
Дякую за увагу
Дякую Катю і я думаю що то цей слайд з
назвами тих ініціатив які вже сьогодні
роблять українські вчені Я дуже важливим
тому що це справді ситуація коли діяла
спасение утопающих дело рук самих
утопающих коли люди роблять якісний
цікавий продукт Я сподіваюсь що наші
глядачі і слухачі скористаються цим
слайдом при перегляді і зайдуть на кожну
сторіночку Зараз ми можемо сфокусуватись
саме на питання книг тому що питання
видавництва книг в Україні зокрема
української мови на науково-популярну на
наукову тематику було достатньо болісним
протягом цих років останнім часом
ситуація дійсно стала краща в тому числі
завдяки тому що українські вчені почали
активно писати а видавці видавати але
давайте послухаємо нашого наступного
доповідача пана Івана будь ласка Я
сьогодні буду тезісна говорит поскольку
мои замечательные коллеги уже основные
главные мысли здесь озвучили кстати мы
не только коллеги а однокашники
випускники практически
Тараса Шевченка и вот в лице Владимир
анатольевича передаем большую
благодарность нашему родному
университету а Что касается наших
издательских миссий наших деятельности
то мы сейчас идем в Трёх направлениях
первое это популяризация
всего наших возможностей
украинской науки в мире А я хотел бы
обратить внимание на проект связанный с
выдаючим свидетелями мировой науки с
украинскими корнями этот проект Моя
существляем уже три года при поддержке
Министерства культуры по заказу
министерстве иностранных дел мы
выпускаем книги а выдающихся деятелях
науки с украинскими корнями и вот в
руках у меня книга которая называется
anselfredit и ukrainians А почему она
называется имена неизвестные украинцы
потому что в мире мы пока есть такая
проблема неизвестная с двух сторон есть
великие ученые
такие как например Александр смакулов
Великий оптик благодаря которому я Вот
например сегодня сижу в очках и могу
Хорошо У вас видеть или Владимир хавкин
великий вирусолог который был главным
вересологом британской короны наше десиц
Спас индию в свое время чумы холеры
многие слышали его в мире но не
ассоциируют его с нашей страной в
Украине вот ему было 120 лет в прошлом
году мы Мне кажется не заслуженно мало
внимание уделяем таким выдающимся
деятелям всегда стоявшим в авангарде
науке а вторая книга которую я держу в
руках э-э это серия книга она называется
легасе Ukraine выдающихся
деятелях современной науки с украинскими
корнями и здесь очень много молодых ліц
который стоят в авангарде современных
инноваций но как тут уже отмечалось К
сожалению большинство из них работает за
пределами Украины чтобы в конце концов
мы могли всегда помогаться на наш
отечественные Научные потенциал
действительно здесь надо вести работу с
ранних лет Все мы занимаются мои коллеги
Открывая Научные музеи работая с детьми
привлекая их современные э-э новые вения
новой школы мы тоже стараемся не
отставаться от этих тенденций и Вот
например сегодня вот сегодня кстати в
зале человеку от Сергей вакарен который
переводит э-э одну из самых
фундаментальных на сегодняшний день книг
э-э с Тима дюкейшен то есть stemo
добавилась буква ай арт уже на
сегодняшний день с тим образования
к нашим реально к нашим
материально-техническим возможностям
научной ментальности и так дальше я
думаю что в ближайшее время это книга
выйдет и
она будет уже изданно с учёвотом наших
возможностей - це учётам потенциала и
развития с тим образования в нашей
стране и мне кажется что сейчас особо
важно обратить внимание в том числе и
государства на сегмент связанный с
литературой для детей э-э которые идёт в
русле о движения к новой школе и не мало
важный вопрос поддержаться материально а
научную литературу которая носит
теоретический
специализированный характер потому что
это далеко некомерческий проект в силу
э-э своей
направленности но без этого науки также
будет тяжело как например без наушных
лабораторий или научно-технических баз А
у нас в стране а на мой взгляд последнее
время уделяется достаточно много
правильного внимания со стороны допустим
Министерства культуры украинского
института книги а к
научно-популярная нонфикшн литературе
художественной литературе министерство
образования уделяет внимание школьным
учебникам Но вот тут учебная литература
научная литература высшей школы Мне
кажется нас здесь а финансово несколько
остаётся в тени с точки зрения поддержки
государства Ну и третье направление о
котором я тоже хотел бы сказать сейчас
целый ряд издательства с тремятся а
наполниться
ринок
наочно-технический переводной
литературой А у нас но наша допустимо
издательство самит книга одним из
принципов такой деятельности
выделяет
возможность потенцию приездать сюда
авторов наиболее прогрессивных
научно-технических книг и зачастую у нас
получается издавать литературу и
привозить сюда авторов которые выступают
в университетах Я хотел бы вот привести
недавние пример кстати тоже выходят с
Украины в Италии галомп
По сути дело а-а Гуру
мирового стартап движения его книга
оксолить стартап стало бестселером в
Америке и впервые на постсоветском
пространстве Она была издана в Украине и
в Италии уже приезжал в нашу страну я
кстати хочу отдельно отметить і по
благодарить социально ориентированные
компании такие как мхп например а
которые поддерживают э-э Ну будем так
говорить не очень простое издательское
дело в нашей стране помогает выпускать
такую нужную литературу э-э мы издавали
совсем недавно и президент то есть кого
университета Петра солов'я которые
специализируется на эмоциональном
інтелекте И сейчас идут переговоры а его
приезде суда и возможно в нашем
Университете откроется центр по
проблематике эмоционального интеллекта и
я думаю что Питер Соловей С радостью
посетит нашу страну вот такая
направленность если тезисна то мы как
издатели видим своё миссию в
популяризации украинской науки в мире И
мы все возможным образом будем
содействовать тому что такие люди как
Лена были в нашей стране и вообще за
рубежом немение извест
шоу бизнеса или спорта потому что
действительно это гордость нашей страны
мы будем всячески прилагать усилия к
работе с самой прогрессивной а-а
научно образовательной литературой для
детей и входим так сказать активно а в
рынок Стим образования и учимся у наших
западных колег а всему самому
современному самому прогрессивному и мы
акцентируем внимание на выпуски здесь
представителей э-э
передовых научных мыслей в Украине
спасибо пока Дякую ми я думаю впевнені в
тому всі тут Що книга це дуже важливо і
підтримка зокрема
науково-популярної книги чи наукової
книги є ключовою для створення
суспільства знань і взяла з блатно
Дивись як ми кажемо Україна інтегрується
в своєму шляху Я сподіваюсь До
суспільства знань до Європейського та
світового дослідницького простору Ми
намагаємося переймати ті найкращі
світові практики те напрацювання які
використовували інші країни для
розбудови суспільства знань у себе і Я
запрошую зараз до слова нашого
спеціального гостя онлайн пана Ніко
мілікоски для того щоб він поділився цим
міжнародним досвідом в розбудові музеїв
науки будь ласка
Дякую
І дякую за те що запросили по-перше хочу
привітати Україну з
30-ю річницею Це дійсно велике
задоволення і велика честь бути з вами
сьогодні
і моя невеличка презентація буде про
яким має бути капітал наукової
суспільства Я вводжу нову концепцію цю
дискусію
центри інтерактивних знань інтерактивної
науки
створюють глобальний рух будь ласка
наступний слайд будь ласка наступний
слайд
за останні
Приблизно 50 років
ідея наукових центрів
вона
[музика]
почалася як величезний рух глобальної у
нас більше трьох тисяч таких наукових
центрів в цьому світі і Я запрошую
Україну Також до нашої
спільнотиці центри науки дуже
успішний в тому що вони надихають
аудиторію ми можемо сказати що разом з
іншими типами музеїв вони
покращують наше
благополуччя і це дуже гарно але в
основному особливо вони впливають на
Вибір кар'єри
молоддю і також
це стосується і ставлення батьків тобто
дітей і які допомагають їм зрозуміти
яким може бути майбутнє через науку
наступний слайд будь ласка всім
думайте глобально діти глобально Я хочу
підкреслити і розказати про декілька
слів про мою країну про Фінляндію ми
можемо сказати що в Фінляндія дуже
добрий відома про успішну систему
шкіл в дослідженнях пісень ми можемо
також Сказати що загальна довіра до
науки
на високому рівні кожного 2 роки є таке
наукове барометр проходить і останній
був проведено в 19-му році і 70% людей
кажуть що їм цікаво наука і вони
довіряють науці і якщо ми тепер
подивимося на кризу пов'язану з кавідом
ми побачимо що рівень вакцинації в нашій
країні досяга майже
80%. Ми можемо зробити висновок що коли
складні часи то тоді довіряють навіть
більше науці якщо ви
довіряєте вакцинуванню то це е-е
показуючи я довіряю науці і мені цікаво
наука тепер сказав що це все гарне про
освіту та науку в моїй країні я хочу
подивитися також на виклики тому що ми
поки що не досягли повного успіху і дуже
багато ще роботи попереду якщо є Тепер
успіх в згідно з дослідженнями Піза це
не означає що ми в майбутньому будемо
успішними ми знаємо що є величезний
розрив знання Між тими хто дійсно є
обізнаний і не ті хто не дотримує
освіти наукової і якщо ми подивимось на
такий самий барометр науки то ми
побачимо що 10% фільмів не довіряють
науці 17 кажучи їм це не цікаво і майже
30%
дослідження погано комуніковані і далі
можуть тільки сказати Про соціальні
мережі І
науково-грамотність дійсно переднести як
великі виклики кожної
день і ми можемо тут запитати де знайти
дослідників завтрашнього дня але тут є
дуже такі цікаві але і непокоїть речі
щодо ситуації в Україні Я думаю ви то
саме запитання ставити собі де ми можемо
знайти у майбутньому людей які будуть
змінювати дослідження і ми маємо бути
певними що ми правильно Працюємо з
формальною системою освіти але цього не
достатньо фактично якщо ми подивимось на
свій життєвий цикл тільки 5%
свого життя ми
проводимо За освітою більшість того що
ми знаємо або те що ми в чому віримо
воно ми отримуємо з інших джерел не з
формальної освіти
якщо ми подивимось на традиційні шляхи
комунікації Про науку А я говорю тепер
про свою професію ми бачимо що
традиційно ми дивимося на
суспільство тобто зверху В чому хочемо
щоб вони знали ми популяризуємо ми якесь
складні речі робимо легкими але або
комунікуємо Про науку і ми говоримо що
важливо знати якщо ми проводимо
проводити
наукову освіту впроваджувати то ми
будемо в правильному напрямку вести
суспільства і ми будемо себе питати тоді
чи можуть вони наші тексти читати
зрозуміти мене правильно я не проти
Не проти цього нам потрібно
популяризація комунікації освіта в науці
грамотність Наукова також нам потрібні
всі ці терміни але хочу підкреслити що
цього недостатньо якщо ми дійсно хочемо
змінити суспільство наступний слайд будь
ласка
тому що в кінці
кінців
суспільства завжди
організує свою власну програму так
працює вільний вибір нами експерти
говоримо що
ми маємо думати про те яким чином
потрібно нам зв'язатися і дати те що
людям здається цікавим і важливим для
життя нам потрібно
мати більше року участь діалог маємо
слухати більше і чути більше також нам
потрібно
[музика]
працювати в співтворенні і дуже часто не
просто використовувати свій досвід та
запрошувати
суспільство щоб вони ще глибше
долучалися до науки та технології
і тепер я хотів би
говорити трошки про таке новий підхід
науковий капітал
що ви знаєте П'єра який я багато років
тому
таку концепцію розробив соціального
капіталу та культурного капіталу Тобто
це те
чим ми можемо
життєвими ситуаціями справитися тепер
кінь з коледж в Лондоні
дослідники
об'єднали цей створили новий вираз
науковий капітал це означає ті ресурси
які Ми створюємо що
до науки в нашому житті дуже важливо
зрозуміти що це стосується не тільки
знань це стосується ставлення нашого
досвіду всього того що ми знаємо і
відчуваємо що до науки у нас менше
однієї хвилини залишилось перепрошуюча
перервало вас так тоді я підведу
підсумок ми маємо дивитися не тільки на
те як ми думаємо на основі знання що
люди думають відчувають щодо науки чи
мають сім'ї навички в науці і останній
слайд будь ласка мій покажіть
Таким чином Я би сказав у завершення Я
хочу сказати що нам потрібен науковий
капітал для всіх тому що майбутні
дослідники вони це фактично ті та молодь
яка надихається наукою яка відчуває що
вона з цього може щось взяти і майбутнє
суспільство яке довіряє науці включно з
тими хто має особисті зв'язки з наукою
це може бути і ва музеї
науки або коли люди читають наукові
журнали або знають когось займаються
дослідженням тому науковий капітал
допомагає нам зрозуміти яким чином
людина може бути надихнута наукою
протягом всього життя це стосується
життя Отож маємо задачу на наступних 30
років будувати Суспільство знань тут в
Україні є певна що тими силами що ми
маємо ми можемо це зробити Дякую І
гарного дня
[оплески]
ось уже завершився перший день нашого
форуму Україна 30 освіта і наука завтра
з 10-ї години Ми продовжимо якщо ви
працюєте у сфері освіти науки цікавитись
цими темами обов'язково долучайтеся до
нас завтра буде цікаво